Hey Craig, you know now that I have a child a baby in the house.
嘿克雷格，你现在知道我家里有一个孩子了。
Do you know what I'm finding it hard to do?
你知道我觉得什么很难做到吗？
What?
什么？
To remember to do?
要记得做什么？
What's that?
那是什么？
Eat food.
吃食物。
Eat food, yes.
吃东西，是的。
That's one of the basic needs that is no longer the priority.
这是基本需求之一，但不再是优先事项。
I know.
我知道。
And I forget.
我忘了。
It's like, oh I forgot to feed Nelson, my dog, and myself.
就像，哦，我忘了喂尼尔森、我的狗和我自己。
So, how are we going to solve that problem?
那么，我们要如何解决这个问题呢？
Well, I just need something quick on the go that I won't, no must, no fuss, I just need to feed myself and get some energy so I can get back to parenting.
好吧，我只是需要一些快速的东西，我不会，没有必要，没有大惊小怪，我只需要养活自己并获得一些能量，这样我就可以回去养育孩子了。
Yes.
是的。
And so, what would solve that problem?
那么，什么可以解决这个问题呢？
I'm going to steer you towards an outcome and the outcome is this product you're about to mention.
我将引导您走向一个结果，而这个结果就是您将要提到的这款产品。
Oh, wait, are you talking about Bavarian meets Little Lamb, Yeager, SnacksTicks?
哦，等等，你是在谈论巴伐利亚遇见小羔羊、耶格尔、SnacksTicks 吗？
The agreed that's what right before we started talking to Zoe said that's what we're going to talk about.
在我们开始与佐伊交谈之前，我们就同意这就是我们要讨论的内容。
Well this is what I want to talk about.
嗯，这就是我想谈的。
The great tasting Bavarian meats, little lamb, yeager, snack sticks, they sent us some of these and they are delicious and they solve the central problem of my life which is I forget to eat.
美味的巴伐利亚肉类、小羊肉、野啤酒、小吃棒，他们给我们送来了一些，它们很美味，解决了我生活中的核心问题，那就是我忘记吃饭。
They're naturally fermented, they're made with real ingredients, slow smoked for bold flavor packed with 9 grams of protein per serving and have zero sugar and zero carbs.
它们是自然发酵的，采用真正的原料制成，缓慢熏制，味道浓郁，每份含有 9 克蛋白质，零糖和零碳水化合物。
So I have a 19 year old boy, also a good moment to get a bunch of this product because he will eat us out of house and home and he loves this stuff.
所以我有一个 19 岁的男孩，也是购买一堆这种产品的好时机，因为他会把我们吃掉，而且他喜欢这些东西。
It's so great.
太棒了。
I'm very grateful.
我非常感激。
We got to sample this.
我们必须对此进行采样。
My son is going to eat it all.
我儿子要把它全部吃掉。
I'm going to have like none of it.
我什么都不会。
But okay, it's a snack that keeps up with your day, whether you're racing between meetings or feeding babies or 19 year olds, doing school drop off, just trying to finish your to-do list, take a moment to save or something delicious for you or your children.
但没关系，它是一种适合你一天的零食，无论你是在赶会议还是喂婴儿或 19 岁的孩子，放学，只是想完成你的待办事项清单，花点时间为你或你的孩子存钱或吃点美味的东西。
Did we mention their portable toss a few in your glove box or gym bag, the diaper bag wherever we have a diaper bag?
我们是否提到过他们在您的手套箱或健身包中以及我们有尿布袋的尿布袋中携带一些便携式物品？
I bet you do Two or three of those bad boys Pick up a pack today your local grocer or stock up at bavarianmeats.com slash podcast use code mother 10 Mother 1 0 at check out for 10% off your first order the very and meat snack sticks great taste zero sugar I could talk for hours about every single episode of how I met your mother and we do But when it comes to my own health, I used to be pretty clueless.
我敢打赌，你有两个或三个坏男孩 今天在当地杂货店买一包，或者在 bavarianmeats.com 上进货 斜线播客使用代码 mother 10 Mother 1 0 在结帐时享受 10% 折扣 你的第一笔订单非常和肉类零食棒味道很棒零糖我可以谈论几个小时关于我如何遇见你母亲和我们的每一集但当谈到我自己的健康时，我曾经非常无能。
I'd shrug off low energy, or fitness plates I was just stressed, basically guessing about what my body actually needed.
我会摆脱低能量或我只是感到压力的健身板，基本上猜测我的身体实际需要什么。
But you shouldn't guess when it comes to your health.
但当涉及到您的健康时，您不应该猜测。
Instead, you should get the real data that supports your wellness with lab core on-demand health testing.
相反，您应该通过实验室核心按需健康测试来获取支持您健康的真实数据。
On the website, you can choose from a suite of more than 100 health tests, including micronutrient allergy, testosterone, fitness, sexual wellness, and more, all available to purchase without a doctor's appointment.
在该网站上，您可以从 100 多项健康测试中进行选择，包括微量营养素过敏、睾酮、健身、性健康等，所有这些都可以在无需医生预约的情况下购买。
Just purchase a test online and visit a local lab core location to have your sample collected.
只需在线购买测试并访问当地实验室核心地点即可收集样本。
It's so simple.
就是这么简单。
With the days, you'll have accurate results that are easy to understand from a lab doctor's trust.
随着时间的推移，您将获得实验室医生信任的易于理解的准确结果。
For your journey, visit ondemand.labcore.com slash mother and use code mother to save up to 15% on select tests.
对于您的旅程，请访问 ondemand.labcore.comlash mother 并使用 code mother 在精选测试中节省高达 15% 的费用。
That's ondemand.labcore.com slash mother and use code mother.
这就是 ondemand.labcore.com 斜线母亲和使用代码母亲。
Know yourself.
了解你自己。
Hi.
你好。
I'm Aaron from Orlando.
我是来自奥兰多的亚伦。
Hi.
你好。
I'm Stacey from Albuquerque, New Mexico.
我是来自新墨西哥州阿尔伯克基的史黛西。
Hi.
你好。
I'm Mimi.
我是咪咪。
I'm in Los Angeles, but for college, I was in the UK.
我在洛杉矶，但上大学时我在英国。
But how I met your mother means to me is that grief is temporary.
但我遇见你母亲的经历对我来说意味着悲伤是暂时的。
It means for me that happiness and humor are both found in the midst of great tragedy.
对我来说，这意味着在巨大的悲剧中可以找到快乐和幽默。
I saw as things happening in my life happened on screen in real time, sometimes even on the same day which was a little weird, but good job.
我看到我生活中发生的事情实时发生在屏幕上，有时甚至是在同一天，这有点奇怪，但做得很好。
The writers in the cast allowed those characters to feel all of those heart breaks without the need for an additional laugh.
演员阵容中的编剧让这些角色感受到所有这些心碎，而不需要额外的笑声。
But unfortunately the episodes didn't err on UK TV at the same time that they aired on US TV.
但不幸的是，这些剧集在英国电视上和美国电视上播出的同时并没有出错。
So yes, I was pirating these episodes, like, rip streaming video link that frequently was reversed.
所以是的，我盗版了这些剧集，例如翻录经常被逆转的流媒体视频链接。
So sometimes in my mind, the entrance to the apartment is on the other side of the screen.
所以有时在我的脑海里，公寓的入口就在屏幕的另一边。
I was reminded that things don't always go as planned, but it happened the way they're supposed to.
有人提醒我，事情并不总是按计划进行，但它却按照预期的方式发生了。
And there's always going to be people around to make sure you're okay.
而且周围总会有人确保您一切安好。
I'm a little, I won't be soon.
我还小，不会很快。
In New York City, when I see you, please permit me to tell you everything.
在纽约，当我见到你时，请允许我告诉你一切。
Hello and welcome to another episode of how we made your mother.
大家好，欢迎收看我们如何塑造你母亲的另一集。
I am Josh Radner.
我是乔什·拉德纳。
I am here with Craig Thomas.
我和克雷格·托马斯在一起。
Hello, everybody.
大家好。
Hello, Craig.
你好，克雷格。
Also, Alec Lev, our producer and savior and Mr. Fix it all.
还有亚历克·列夫（Alec Lev），我们的制作人、救世主，以及“修复一切”先生。
And it's only our second episode, but we are already on a very special episode of how we made your mother.
这只是我们的第二集，但我们已经在制作一个非常特别的剧集，讲述我们如何创造了你的母亲。
It's very special because we have Carter bays with us.
这很特别，因为我们有卡特海湾。
No, I agree.
不，我同意。
Hi guys.
嗨，大家好。
How are you?
你好吗？
We're really good.
我们真的很好。
Carter bays.
卡特湾。
Well, tell us why you're here, Carter.
好吧，告诉我们你为什么来这里，卡特。
What hand did you have in the how I met your mother verse?
在《我如何遇见你母亲》这首诗中，你扮演了什么角色？
I'm pretty, I was there for a good deal of it.
我很漂亮，我在那里度过了很多时光。
I'm getting a lot of props I remember.
我得到了很多我记得的道具。
Yeah.
是的。
It's my props.
这是我的道具。
Yeah.
是的。
It's my props.
这是我的道具。
Yeah.
是的。
I was a...
我是一个...
I'm...
我是...
Carden Craig.
卡登·克雷格.
I'm the carder of Carden Craig.
我是卡登·克雷格的卡片员。
No, no, no.
不，不，不。
Carder and Craig.
卡德和克雷格。
I wish I'd pretended I didn't know Carder was the guest so we could have done the smartless thing.
我希望我假装不知道卡德是客人，这样我们就可以做愚蠢的事情。
Oh, my God.
我的天啊。
It's Carder.
是卡德尔。
So welcome, Carder.
欢迎，卡德。
We're so happy you're here.
我们很高兴你在这里。
It's good to be here.
很高兴来到这里。
Yeah.
是的。
So I love this story.
所以我喜欢这个故事。
This is kind of an iconic origin story for me that you guys have told me, but I want you to tell our audience.
这对我来说是一个标志性的起源故事，是你们告诉我的，但我希望你们告诉我们的观众。
So Matt, you brought him three ideas, five ideas.
所以马特，你给他带来了三个想法，五个想法。
How many ideas did you bring Matt?
你给马特带来了多少想法？
Editor's note.
编者注。
Josh is talking about Matt Rice, who is Craig and Carter's TV agent.
乔什正在谈论马特·赖斯，他是克雷格和卡特的电视经纪人。
How many ideas did you bring Matt?
你给马特带来了多少想法？
Probably a lot.
可能很多。
Probably more.
可能更多。
Probably 10.
大概是10个。
I mean, I'm just throwing out ideas and throwing out titles and areas and we said that kind of like one line pitches or just like very bearable ideas.
我的意思是，我只是扔掉一些想法，扔掉标题和领域，我们说这有点像一条线的间距，或者只是像非常可以忍受的想法。
Kind of like log ones for like areas of what it could be.
有点像类似区域的日志。
There was like one of them was like a David Spade vehicle.
其中一辆就像一辆大卫·斯佩德的车。
I think Jason David Spade.
我认为是贾森·大卫·斯佩德。
I remember a document.
我记得有一个文件。
I think there was like four things like we had a it was it was it was it King's Road Cafe or was it toast?
我想有四件事就像我们有一个是它是它是国王路咖啡馆还是它是吐司？
It was one of these two places.
这是这两个地方之一。
King's Road Cafe, I think.
我想是国王路咖啡馆。
I was getting wrong but we had a meeting with Matt and over breakfast and we were like to present our four ideas and I think the first one we read was is how I met your mother.
我错了，但我们与马特会面并吃早餐，我们想提出我们的四个想法，我想我们读到的第一个想法是我如何认识你母亲的。
And he was like, that's it.
他说，就是这样。
That's the one.
就是这个。
You can read me the other ones, but that's the one.
你可以给我读其他的，但只有这一个。
And it was kind of like a tip.
这有点像小费。
Do you remember what the kind of like log line of it was?
你还记得它是什么样的日志行吗？
I think in light, this sort of storytelling perspective built into the title.
我认为，从角度来看，这种讲故事的视角已经融入到了标题中。
And then when we started talking about how personal it would be to us, that it would be sort of like the couple that's a little bit like me and my wife and the single guy that's a little bit like Carter at the time.
然后当我们开始谈论这对我们来说有多么个人化时，这有点像我和我妻子的一对夫妇，以及当时有点像卡特的单身汉。
I think he was just like, that's where your heart is.
我认为他就像，那就是你的心所在。
Your heart is and you know had to write that.
你的心是，你知道必须写下来。
But he had, he had, his reaction was more like visceral and immediate.
但他做到了，他做到了，他的反应更像是本能的、直接的。
It was almost a little more magical than that.
它几乎比那更神奇一点。
The more we talked about it, the more it was like that also was right.
越聊越觉得这也是对的。
What you know, do that one.
你所知道的，就去做吧。
You don't know the worlds of these other things you're pitching right, your world.
你不知道你正在推销的其他事物的世界，你的世界。
And we went from New York, we missed New York.
我们从纽约出发，我们想念纽约。
That was part of the flavor of the show or nostalgia for having left what was our home for a bunch of years.
这是这部剧的味道的一部分，也是对离开我们的家好几年的怀念。
And he's like, you, you can do that.
他说，你，你可以做到的。
That's going to bring out the heart.
这样才能把心掏出来。
Right, Carter?
对吧，卡特？
He was, he's, I mean, he's a softie and he's got a, he's got a real emotional core that Matt And he, I think, you know, he's kind of our age is a little bit older, but like, I think he wanted to see what we could do just writing about because Oliver Bean was about a 12 year old kid living in the 1960s and then we're writing American dad, we're writing all these shows that were like sort of not, not, not our, we worked on the method and read sitcom.
他是，他是，我的意思是，他是一个软弱的人，他有一个真正的情感核心，马特，他，我想，你知道，他的年龄比我们大一点，但是，我想他想看看我们能做些什么，因为奥利弗·比恩是关于一个生活在 1960 年代的 12 岁孩子，然后我们正在写美国爸爸，我们正在写所有这些节目，就像不是，不，不是我们的，我们研究了该方法并阅读了情景喜剧。
So I mean, Method Man is not, we aren't the natural choices to have the voice of Method Man, but, but yeah, I think he just saw that it was like, oh, this is going to be.
所以我的意思是，Method Man 不是，我们不是拥有 Method Man 声音的自然选择，但是，但是，是的，我认为他只是看到了，哦，这将会是。
Craig and Carter really writing their own lives and talking about stuff that's going on with them and and that's that's exciting that's the there's a vulnerability to it that I think was that appeal to us to I think and to Matt's credit also the second thing we pitched was a show that we had no business writing that that we ended up selling to Fox and and I think Matt always knew he was like you know you can sell this one but how many mothers gonna be the one that ends up going and and and low old.
克雷格和卡特真的在写自己的生活，谈论他们正在发生的事情，这很令人兴奋，这就是它有一个弱点，我认为这对我们很有吸引力，我认为，马特的功劳也是我们推销的第二件事是一部我们没有业务写的节目，我们最终卖给了福克斯，我想马特一直都知道他就像你知道你可以卖掉这个，但有多少母亲会成为那个最终走低的人老了。
Thank God.
感谢上帝。
Wow.
哇。
Boy, do you realize that when you sit down to write them, you sit down to write one and you have a bajillion ideas and the other one, you're like, I don't know how to get to page 10 on this one.
男孩，你是否意识到，当你坐下来写它们时，你坐下来写一个，你有无数的想法，而另一个，你就像，我不知道如何到达第 10 页。
There's not going to be nine seasons of this.
这个不会有九季。
So did you have to, I mean, I know you're getting paid by 20th century Fox and kind of like a holding deal.
那么你是否必须这样做，我的意思是，我知道你正在从 20 世纪福克斯公司获得报酬，有点像控股交易。
You can't write for anyone else.
你不能为别人写作。
But did he just say go write this pilot, go write how I met your mother?
但他只是说去写这个试播集，去写我是如何认识你母亲的吗？
We pitched it verbally.
我们口头上提出了这个建议。
We didn't write it.
不是我们写的。
We pitched both verbally and you go around town, you go to ABC at the, you know, at the time, there was no streamers.
我们都是口头推销的，然后你到城里走走，你去美国广播公司 (ABC)，你知道，当时没有彩带。
Again, old CFO are mentioned, incredibly old people.
再次提到了老首席财务官，非常老的人。
And you go, you drive in person, no Zoom meetings, you drive to NBC, you drive to Fox, you drive to CBS, and you pitch them these ideas.
然后你亲自开车去，没有 Zoom 会议，你开车去 NBC，你开车去福克斯，你开车去哥伦比亚广播公司，然后你向他们推销这些想法。
And we did, we did the rounds for both of those ideas.
我们确实这么做了，我们对这两个想法进行了多次讨论。
So we pitched all the same people, both of those ideas.
所以我们向同一个人推销了这两种想法。
One of them, we sold the Fox, which was like the parent company of our deal.
其中之一是，我们出售了福克斯，它就像我们交易的母公司。
They were in the the vertical integration of the deal, they didn't get high, they didn't want how much your mother though.
他们处于交易的垂直整合中，他们没有兴奋，但他们不想要你妈妈多少钱。
We pitched it.
我们投了它。
How much your mother got a bunch of passes?
你妈妈买了一堆通行证多少钱？
We didn't, you know, landed at CBS.
你知道，我们并没有登陆哥伦比亚广播公司。
We thought it was an landed NBC, but that didn't work out and CBS really wanted it.
我们以为这是一个登陆 NBC 的节目，但这并没有成功，哥伦比亚广播公司真的很想要它。
They really, it was just the moment that they were looking for a younger show.
他们真的，这正是他们寻找更年轻的节目的时刻。
I don't know if people, I mean, I guess maybe CBS is still like this, but like at the time, especially it was like such a, it was family sitcoms, it was King Queens, everybody loves Raymond.
我不知道人们是否，我的意思是，我想也许哥伦比亚广播公司仍然是这样，但就像当时一样，尤其是这样，它是家庭情景喜剧，它是 King Queens，每个人都喜欢雷蒙德。
It was two and a half.
已经两岁半了。
Two and a half shows.
演出两场半。
all this demo, right?
所有这些演示，对吗？
Like it didn't have the old historians of the image that were like lettermen used to do jokes all the time about like the old people watching, you know, it's like Matt Locke in his show and like that's like, yeah, that's CBS and 60 minutes, you know, you know.
就像它没有老历史学家那样的图像，就像莱特曼过去一直开玩笑一样，就像老人们在观看一样，你知道，就像马特·洛克在他的节目中一样，就像，是的，那是 CBS 的 60 分钟，你知道，你知道。
So so when you when you pitched the show and CBS buys it, did you have the names Ted Marshall Lily Barney Robin with those character?
所以当你推销这部剧并被哥伦比亚广播公司买下时，你有泰德·马歇尔·莉莉·巴尼·罗宾这个角色的名字吗？
They were fully formed at that point.
那时他们已经完全成形了。
We went in with that fully formed pitch sheet.
我们带着完全成型的宣传单进来了。
Yeah, we had, we had each character and like you write up a little description of each character, maybe eight or 10 episode ideas, just in the shape of how the storytelling work, when you, you pitch them sort of like 15 or 20 minutes of like through this pitch document, you're going to give them a flavor of what it will be.
是的，我们有每个角色，就像你写下每个角色的一些描述，也许八到十集的想法，只是以讲故事的方式进行，当你通过这个推介文件向他们推销大约 15 或 20 分钟时，你会给他们一个大概的感觉。
And by far the best response in the room was CBS.
到目前为止，房间里反应最好的是哥伦比亚广播公司(CBS)。
These wonderful women of CBS who got the emotion and the heart behind you.
哥伦比亚广播公司 (CBS) 的这些出色的女性为您提供了情感和心灵支持。
Wendy Trilling, Julie Purnworth, Edie Mendoza.
温迪·特里林、朱莉·珀恩沃斯、伊迪·门多萨。
And these, and they got what this was and they had just been in a meeting with their higher ups there where they all the directive was we want a younger skimming basically we want it from we want friends which we did not want to a come and just give them a friend's clone but it definitely helped us that yes wanted a friend yeah it was um I believe it was like really it was like hauntingly good timing like it was it was like that morning they had had a meeting and and it was like I think the way I heard it phrase was we're getting in the under 35 game was how they said it like we need to go you a development department go find us a show for people under 35 guys we want to get the under 100 years old.
这些，他们得到了这是什么，他们刚刚和他们的上级开会，他们所有的指示都是我们想要一个年轻的略读基本上我们想要它来自我们想要的朋友，我们不想来，只是给他们一个朋友的克隆，但这确实帮助了我们，是的想要一个朋友是的，是的，嗯，我相信这真的是一个令人难以忘怀的好时机，就像那天早上他们开了一个会议，就像我认为我听到这句话的方式是我们要参加 35 岁以下的比赛，他们是这么说的，就像我们需要去开发部门给我们找一个适合 35 岁以下的人的节目，我们想让 100 岁以下的人参加。
You guys were ready with the work and then that was a stroke of luck and timing that was it's fantastic for you guys we had to be in the place that that really wanted us and like if we had ended up at NBC like they had three other or how many of your mothers loaded in the chamber.
你们已经准备好工作了，然后这是一次运气和时机，这对你们来说太棒了，我们必须到达真正需要我们的地方，就像我们最终在 NBC 一样，就像他们还有另外三个人或有多少个母亲在房间里一样。
Like, we might have been still on.
就像，我们可能还在继续。
It would have been.
本来就是这样。
We had friends that just finished.
我们有朋友刚刚完成。
Friends that just finished.
刚刚结束的朋友们。
And I think we would have been so, as much as we dreaded those comparisons to friends, imagine if we had been like the year friends ended, like and here's this other one, it wouldn't have, it somehow wouldn't have worked, but we in the moment, we should say, we did not expect to be at CBS, and we were worried with the shows too young, it's not gonna work there.
我认为我们会如此，尽管我们害怕与朋友进行比较，想象一下，如果我们像《朋友》结束的那一年一样，就像这是另一个，它就不会，它在某种程度上不会起作用，但我们现在，我们应该说，我们没想到会在哥伦比亚广播公司，我们担心节目太年轻，在那里不会起作用。
And look, it went nine seasons and people believed in it that worked there.
看，它已经播出了九季，人们相信它在那里起作用。
It was important.
这很重要。
So it was, it was an amazing bit of luck.
原来如此，真是太幸运了。
and I wrote you this little day to send you a new York City.
今天我写信给你，是想给你寄一张纽约市的照片。
We'll be right back.
我们马上回来。
You know, there was a time when I would ignore or maybe not even notice when my sheets started slipping off the corners or peeling or when my pillows weren't quite as supportive as I wanted them to be.
你知道，曾经有一段时间，当我的床单开始从角落滑落或剥落，或者当我的枕头没有我想要的那么支撑时，我会忽略或什至没有注意到。
My wife, however, has always noticed this sort of thing.
然而，我的妻子总是注意到这种事情。
But now that we got a baby waking up at, you know, various times, every moment of sleep has become invaluable.
但现在我们有了一个婴儿，你知道，在不同的时间醒来，每一刻的睡眠都变得非常宝贵。
And I am so delighted that Bull and Branch sent us some of the comfiest sheets that I have ever had the pleasure to sleep upon.
我很高兴 Bull 和 Branch 给我们送来了一些最舒适的床单，我曾经很高兴睡在上面。
Their organic cotton bedding is designed for deep uninterrupted rest, which is what we're getting.
他们的有机棉床上用品专为深度不间断的休息而设计，这正是我们所得到的。
The sheets are incredibly soft.
床单非常柔软。
They're breathable, and it's a total game-changer for our energy levels, especially with this young, occasionally sleeping baby we have now.
它们透气，这对我们的能量水平来说是一个彻底的改变，尤其是对于我们现在这个偶尔睡觉的小婴儿来说。
This is the kind of comfort we can't afford to compromise anymore.
这是我们不能再妥协的舒适感。
Upgrade your sleep with Bowling Branch, get 15% off your first order, plus free shipping at BowlingBranch.com slash your mother with code, your mother.
通过 Bowling Branch 升级您的睡眠，首次订单可享受 15% 折扣，并在 BowlingBranch.com 上享受免费送货，用代码砍掉您的母亲，您的母亲。
That's bull in branch, B-O-L-L-A-N-D branch dot com slash your mother, code your mother to unlock 15% off exclusion's apply.
这是分支中的公牛，B-O-L-L-A-N-D 分支 . com 削减你的母亲，编码你的母亲以解锁排除适用的 15% 折扣。
Alec, you know what happened to me when I found a good therapist?
亚历克，你知道当我找到一位好的治疗师后我发生了什么吗？
What happened to you when you found a good therapist?
当你找到一位好的治疗师后，你发生了什么？
I married her.
我娶了她。
Oh!
哦！
My wife Jordana is a therapist, a wonderful therapist, but today we're talking about RULA, which I believe Alec, you have used and can tell us a little more about.
我的妻子 Jordana 是一位治疗师，一位出色的治疗师，但今天我们谈论的是 RULA，我相信 Alec 您已经使用过它，并且可以告诉我们更多相关信息。
I can and I would like to announce first that I did not marry a single one of the therapists that I have used.
我可以而且我想首先宣布，我没有与我所使用的治疗师中的任何一位结婚。
It's good to say that right up front.
最好提前说清楚。
Disclaimer.
免责声明。
Yes.
是的。
No rule is it's fantastic.
没有规则是它太棒了。
It's a way of finding an online therapist and I have used them for years.
这是寻找在线治疗师的一种方式，我已经使用它们很多年了。
It's basically built the way you would want a kind of website like this to be built.
它基本上是按照您想要的类似网站的方式构建的。
you go on and you get to tell a little bit about what you're looking for and you get a list of therapists and they can be anywhere because this is entirely online so you have a very large list.
你继续下去，你可以告诉你一些你正在寻找的东西，你会得到一份治疗师名单，他们可以在任何地方，因为这完全是在线的，所以你有一个非常大的名单。
And they'll tell you about themselves.
他们会告诉你关于他们自己的事情。
They have great bios of what brought them to this work, what interests them, what kind of work they've done in the past, what their techniques are, and you get to get a sense of who they are, which is completely different from we just walk into a therapist's office.
他们有很好的简历，告诉他们是什么让他们从事这项工作，他们感兴趣什么，他们过去做过什么样的工作，他们的技术是什么，你可以了解他们是谁，这与我们走进治疗师的办公室完全不同。
You're just meeting this person for the first time and what's really great about it is you can change and you could change because the fit isn't quite right or just actually just recently I changed because it had been a long time with one therapist and I just sort of had a sense that it was time to change and Rula makes it so easy you just go you have your list of therapists and you can just choose whoever you feel is the right fit for you.
你只是第一次见到这个人，真正伟大的是你可以改变，你可以改变，因为不太适合你，或者实际上最近我才改变，因为和一位治疗师在一起已经很长时间了，我只是有一种感觉，是时候改变了，Rula 让一切变得如此简单，你只需去你的治疗师名单，你就可以选择任何你认为最适合你的人。
It almost sounds like Rula and I hope they're okay with me saying this.
这听起来几乎像鲁拉，我希望他们同意我这么说。
It's like a Somali for therapists.
这就像治疗师的索马里语。
It is, it's exactly what it is.
是的，就是这样。
You've got to spot what you're looking for, and they say, I have a lovely, I have a lovely person in Denver, Colorado for you.
你必须找到你要找的东西，他们说，我在科罗拉多州丹佛市有一个可爱的人在找你。
That's right, and they give you just a little bit, you just take a little sip for at first.
是的，他们只给你一点点，你一开始只喝一点。
You just have your one appointment, see if it fits, and if not, you send it back, and you get that next bottle.
您只需进行一次预约，看看它是否合适，如果不合适，您将其退回，然后您会得到下一瓶。
And I can attest as Alex's longtime friend.
作为亚历克斯的老朋友，我可以作证。
He used to be, at least to be a mess, and now he's He's all he's doing great you knew me in the pre-Rula days those were dark days Yeah, I didn't I don't wish you would pre-rula on anymore But they've done great work with you.
他过去是，至少是一团糟，现在他是了，他所做的一切都很棒，你在前规则时代就认识我了，那是黑暗的日子是的，我不知道，我不希望你再继续前规则，但他们和你一起做了很棒的工作。
You're you're a shining example of what can happen Rula helps you find licensed therapists and psychiatrists who truly align with your background in goals rather than just assigning you the first open slot available.
你就是一个光辉的例子，Rula 可以帮助你找到真正符合你目标背景的有执照的治疗师和精神科医生，而不是仅仅为你分配第一个可用的空缺职位。
Even better, Rula, R-U-L-A, works with over 100 major insurance plans nationwide, bringing the average session copay to just $15.
更好的是，Rula（R-U-L-A）与全国 100 多个主要保险计划合作，使平均疗程自付额仅为 15 美元。
They support you from day one, tracking your milestones and helping you monitor your care along the way to ensure you are actually moving forward.
他们从第一天起就为您提供支持，跟踪您的里程碑并帮助您全程监控您的护理，以确保您真正取得进展。
Thousands of people are already using Rula to get affordable high-quality therapy that's actually covered by insurance.
成千上万的人已经在使用 Rula 来获得负担得起的高质量治疗，而且这些治疗实际上是由保险承保的。
Visit rulea.com slash your mother to get started.
访问rulea.com 砍掉你的母亲即可开始。
That's Rula-R-U-L-A.com.
这就是 Rula-R-U-L-A.com。
Slash your mother.
砍你妈。
You deserve mental health care that works with you not against your budget.
您应该得到适合您的心理健康护理，而不是超出您的预算。
Snapple would like you to take a break from the sheds.
斯内普尔希望你能离开棚屋休息一下。
Those things you should be doing should be finishing should be thinking about.
那些你应该做、应该完成的事情、应该思考。
Well right now just crack open a snaple and just sit tight for a minute while Craig and I share some snaple real facts with you not unlike Mr. Mosby's fun facts.
好吧，现在就打开一个斯奈普，坐一会儿，克雷格和我与你分享一些斯奈普的真实事实，就像莫斯比先生的有趣事实一样。
Mr. Ted Mosby would have a lot of his fun facts.
特德·莫斯比先生会有很多有趣的事实。
He would love these and some of these are even an architecture related so give us our first fact.
他会喜欢这些，其中一些甚至与架构相关，所以请告诉我们第一个事实。
What do you got?
你有什么？
These all feel like things Ted or at least like a future like dad Ted would say.
这些都感觉像是泰德的事情，或者至少像泰德爸爸所说的未来。
All right, here is a Snapple Real Facts, 253.
好吧，这是 Snapple 的真实事实，253。
The first TV remote control introduced in 1950 was called Lazy Bones.
1950 年推出的第一个电视遥控器被称为“Lazy Bones”。
I didn't know that.
我不知道。
I mean, I mean, either.
我的意思是，我的意思是，要么。
Real Facts, 1517 in New York.
真实的事实，1517 年在纽约。
It is illegal to sell a haunted house without telling the buyer.
在未告知买家的情况下出售鬼屋是违法的。
That's actually amazing.
这实际上是惊人的。
And that feels like a very, that feels like a very martial, actually.
实际上，这感觉就像是一种非常、非常武术的感觉。
These are weirdly resonant.
这些产生了奇怪的共鸣。
Okay, fact, that's, that is amazing and I wanna know more but we don't have time for it in the snaple chat.
好吧，事实上，这太棒了，我想了解更多，但我们没有时间在 snaple 聊天中了解它。
Real facts, 1978, 1,978, I'm gonna think that's nothing to do with the year in 1978.
真实的事实，1978年，1,978年，我认为这与1978年无关。
More than 40 buildings in New York have their own zip codes.
纽约有 40 多座建筑物都有自己的邮政编码。
That is totally a Ted Mosby fund.
这完全是泰德·莫斯比基金。
That is.
那是。
He would actually know that.
他实际上会知道这一点。
He told every girlfriend that.
他对每个女朋友都这么说。
Snaple real fact, 1,667.
斯内普真实事实，1,667。
Lovebirds are actual birds.
爱情鸟是真正的鸟类。
And we bring it back to love.
我们把它带回爱。
It's all full circle.
这都是完整的循环。
It's all very him yummy.
这一切都非常美味。
All right, that's your break quick fun And just a little unexpected next time you hit pause and make a count with Snapple on your next break When you guys pitched it to all those places around town Did you have the 40 to 60 same narrative structure or was that something you discovered while you were writing?
好吧，这就是你的快速休息乐趣，下次当你按下暂停键并在下一次休息时用 Snapple 进行计数时，你会感到有点意外当你们把它推广到镇上的所有地方时，你们有 40 到 60 个相同的叙事结构吗？或者这是您在写作时发现的东西？
I think we had and that's how I met your aunt Robin and I know we had that.
我想我们有过这样的经历，这就是我认识你罗宾阿姨的方式，我知道我们有过这样的经历。
I don't know if we had like the the like every scene beaten out for sure, but we definitely, I don't think we had like a season arc of any kind, which I think nowadays, you know, like in hindsight, you know, this wasn't a place that wanted a season arc.
我不知道我们是否有像这样的每个场景都被淘汰，但我们绝对，我不认为我们有任何类型的季节弧，我认为现在，你知道，事后看来，你知道，这不是一个想要季节弧的地方。
Again, this is, this is, this is a CBS in 2005, like, like, what's the season arc on King of Queens?
再说一遍，这是，这是，这是 2005 年的 CBS，就像，《皇后之王》的这一季剧情是什么？
Like, it's, there is no arc.
就像，没有弧线。
It's the same show 22 times in a row.
同一场演出连续演出22次。
We never even found out who the king was.
我们甚至不知道国王是谁。
I never even answered that.
我什至从未回答过这个问题。
Actually, that's worth also pointing out to our listeners who are using magical devices to listen to all this.
事实上，这也值得向我们使用神奇设备来收听这一切的听众指出。
Like the notion that it's a big deal that how I met your mother really needs to be seen from beginning to end.
就像我如何认识你母亲这件大事确实需要从头到尾地看一样。
You could pop in if you wanted to, but nowadays on Netflix, of course you're doing that.
如果你愿意的话，你可以插播，但现在在 Netflix 上，你当然会这么做。
You're just watching it straight in a row.
你只是连续看着它。
So can you just talk a little bit about that style of sitcom at the time that this was very different?
那么你能谈谈当时情景喜剧的风格吗？这是非常不同的？
Yeah.
是的。
It's funny.
很有趣。
I'm having a fight with my daughter right now about this very thing because now it's advanced to like, she's somehow got her hands on the TikTok.
我现在正在和我女儿就这件事吵架，因为现在已经很先进了，她不知何故掌握了 TikTok。
We've like, we've like, you know, we thought we'd barred up all the windows, but it's honest way into the cellar or something.
我们喜欢，我们喜欢，你知道，我们以为我们已经把所有的窗户都关上了，但这是通往地窖之类的诚实的方式。
And like, she's watching like, like, cut downs of scenes on TikTok and like, finding out twists in the series.
就像，她正在观看 TikTok 上的场景剪辑之类的，寻找剧集中的曲折。
And I'm like, no.
我想，不。
both of us sit down and watch this together, just like the kid and the kids.
我们俩坐下来一起看这一切，就像孩子和孩子们一样。
There's gonna be a whole thing, but yeah.
会有一整件事，但是是的。
Anyway, at the time we were, Craig and I, I think our favorite show on TV at that time was Buffy the Vampire Slayer, which we had both devoured on, like it was right at the dawn of like the DVD box set, like the season box set.
无论如何，当时我们，克雷格和我，我想我们当时最喜欢的电视节目是《吸血鬼猎人巴菲》，我们都如饥似渴地观看了它，就像它刚刚开始一样，就像 DVD 盒装，就像季盒装一样。
And we loved these CVD, because they told individual stories, like each episode, it's the one where this happened, the one where that happened, but they're beautifully laid out as in this season-long arc that has this big satisfying conclusion at the end of the season.
我们喜欢这些 CVD，因为它们讲述了单独的故事，就像每一集一样，就是发生这种情况的那一集，就是发生这种情况的那一集，但它们的布局很漂亮，就像在这个长达一季的弧线中一样，在季末有一个令人满意的大结局。
And I remember thinking our goal, when it's like we're gonna make a show, was like, if the show makes it a full season, we're not even gonna hope for more than one season, but just to have, to make something that there's a DVD box set of.
我记得我们的目标是，当我们要制作一部剧时，如果这部剧制作一整季，我们甚至不会希望超过一季，而只是制作一些有 DVD 盒装的东西。
Oh yeah.
哦，是的。
I think that was the goal.
我认为这就是目标。
I feel like there was nothing else that I was like, we said it would be like a novel on our shelf.
我觉得没有什么是我喜欢的，我们说这就像我们书架上的一本小说。
right, Carter, we're like, I want that little spine.
是的，卡特，我们就像，我想要那个小脊椎。
I want the spine that says, how much I'm under, even if it gets canceled, we always have that one little novel says thing of a technology that's going to disappear in five years is what it was like right before or right around the time, the whole, I think of my show as a novel became a cliche.
我想要的书脊说，我有多沮丧，即使它被取消了，我们总是有一本小小说说五年后就会消失的技术就是在那个时候之前或前后的样子，整个，我认为我的节目作为一本小说变成了陈词滥调。
But it was like right before it became a cliche.
但这就像在成为陈词滥调之前一样。
We were the first ones to say that bullshit line.
我们是第一个说这句废话的人。
But it was like, yeah, I mean, that was an, and, you know, CBS, when we pitched it, didn't say, like, what happens in episode two, what happens in episode five, which should have clued us in because, you know, we, you know, we wanted to tell it, you know, we felt like this is the first chapter of a saga, like, this is, we're going to tell a story and it, it, I mean, and maybe this is a discussion for down the road, but it became, there, there was some, there was some big disagreements about, like, what kind of show we were making because they wanted to show that anyone who hasn't seen the show can just jump right in on, on, you You know, on any given Monday in February and just drop right in and be like, okay, I got it.
但这就像，是的，我的意思是，那是一个，而且，你知道，哥伦比亚广播公司，当我们推销它时，没有说，比如，第二集发生了什么，第五集发生了什么，这应该给我们提供线索，因为，你知道，我们，你知道，我们想讲述它，你知道，我们觉得这是一个传奇的第一章，就像，这是，我们要讲一个故事，它，它，我的意思是，也许这是接下来的讨论路，但它变成了，那里，有一些，关于我们要制作什么样的节目，有一些很大的分歧，因为他们想表明，任何没有看过这个节目的人都可以直接加入，你知道，在二月的任何一个星期一，直接加入并说，好吧，我明白了。
I see what's going on.
我明白发生了什么事。
And I can watch this.
我可以看这个。
Whereas Craig and I, we had our eyes on, you know, the season box set.
而克雷格和我，我们关注的是，你知道的，本季套装。
We had our eyes on like, we're making something that people sit down and devote a whole afternoon when they're sick and bad to just like watching season one of How Me Your Mother.
我们的目标是，我们正在制作一些东西，让人们在生病或身体不好时坐下来花一整个下午的时间，就像观看《How Me Your Mother》第一季一样。
But at the beginning, we really looked 15 years old.
但一开始，我们看起来真的只有15岁。
We'd never run a TV show.
我们从来没有经营过电视节目。
We were running these weird 70 scene scripts in 21 minutes.
我们在 21 分钟内运行了这些奇怪的 70 个场景脚本。
They took a second for them to kind of understand can this fit into the Monday night lineup?
他们花了一点时间才明白这是否适合周一晚上的阵容？
It really strikes me that it's so hard to create something new in Hollywood in that structure that moves so glacial.
让我印象深刻的是，在好莱坞这样一个冰冷的结构中创造出新的东西是非常困难的。
You know, like, I think what was too smart about the way you guys conceived of this show is like five friends hanging out had been done and seen before.
你知道，我认为你们对这个节目的构思太聪明了，就像以前做过和见过的五个朋友一起出去玩一样。
But you have this other thing of like framed as a flashback, the nonlinear structure, this kind of wildly inventive news story telling, I used to tell people they would say, what's the show like that you're doing?
但是你还有其他类似的东西，比如倒叙、非线性结构、这种极具创意的新闻故事讲述方式，我曾经告诉人们他们会说，你正在做的节目是什么样的？
And I'd say, it's like if Pulp Fiction was a sitcom, you know, there was something about the way it was a puzzle, right?
我想说，如果《低俗小说》是一部情景喜剧，你知道，它就像一个谜题，对吧？
And sometimes there were episodes that were very puzzle-like of how I met your mother where just like Ted Mosby architect is like a very strange mystery, right, until you get what's happening at the end.
有时，有些情节非常像我如何遇见你母亲的谜题，就像泰德·莫斯比建筑师一样，就像一个非常奇怪的谜团，对吧，直到你明白最后发生了什么。
And it rewards your patience and fidelity to it, which is why I think one, it scared probably the network, but two, I think that's what created some of the fervor and excitement and loyalty to the show among the hardcore fans was they got invested in a different way because they felt like they were growing alongside or with the characters.
它会奖励你的耐心和对它的忠诚，这就是为什么我认为第一，它可能会吓到电视网，但第二，我认为这就是铁杆粉丝对这部剧产生热情、兴奋和忠诚的原因，因为他们以不同的方式进行投资，因为他们觉得自己正在与角色一起成长。
Yeah, I think the audience felt respected and the audience felt like they were sort of our accomplices in this little weird kind of mystery crime we were trying to pull off and they felt invested.
是的，我认为观众感到受到尊重，感觉他们是我们试图完成的这种奇怪的神秘犯罪的同谋，他们感到投入。
And it's funny how a lot of the best episodes of how much mother are mini mysteries within this larger mystery.
有趣的是，在这个更大的谜团中，有多少关于母亲多少的最佳剧集都是迷你谜团。
That's another thing that I always kind of love about what works on that show on earth.
这是我一直喜欢地球上那个节目的另一件事。
Yeah.
是的。
But like being able to use that device for puzzle building was always fun like like episodes like three days of snow.
但是，能够使用该设备来构建谜题总是很有趣，就像三天的雪一样。
I don't know if you remember that one, but like like or the burning beekeeper.
我不知道你是否还记得那个，但就像《燃烧的养蜂人》一样。
Things that really like you know Like Pulp Fiction was absolutely, I mean, I don't think anyone our age who was in the movies wasn't, didn't catch some, some, uh, uh, uh, flag from that, like just just, like just the, the, the, the creative energy just, uh, vibrating off of it, like, I feel like it, it's way.
那些真正像你知道的事情，比如《低俗小说》，我的意思是，我认为我们这个年纪的电影里的人都没有捕捉到一些，一些，呃，呃，呃，其中的标志，就像只是，就像只是，那个，那个，创造性的能量只是，呃，从它身上振动，就像，我觉得它，就是这样。
I remember, uh, uh, when I read episode two after the show had been picked up, I was so delighted that the DNA of what I loved about the pilot was just even more there in the second episode.
我记得，呃，呃，当我在节目播出后读到第二集时，我非常高兴，因为我对试播集的喜爱在第二集中更加明显。
I was like, oh, it's just going to keep moving like this.
我当时想，哦，它会继续这样移动。
And I was delighted by it.
我对此感到很高兴。
So I do want to ask you guys, CBS says yes.
所以我想问你们，哥伦比亚广播公司说是的。
They're not going to make the pilot.
他们不会做飞行员。
They order a script.
他们订购了一个剧本。
Is that right?
是这样吗？
Yeah, they order a script.
是的，他们订了一个剧本。
You write the pilot script and submit some episode ideas for future episodes, which we already were kind of had and probably mentioned in the pitch, but then you more formally do that along with the script.
你编写试播剧本，并为未来的剧集提交一些剧集创意，这些创意我们已经有了，并且可能在宣传中提到过，但随后你会更正式地与剧本一起完成这些创意。
You spent a whole fall of some projects, fall of 2004.
2004 年秋天，你花了整整一个秋天的时间来完成一些项目。
We're writing on American Dad and then at night, right on the weekend, writing...
我们正在写《美国爸爸》，然后在晚上，就在周末，写……
Your district was how I lived.
你所在的地区就是我的生活方式。
And the other...
而另一个...
Is that your district?
那是你的区吗？
Torrid Hot Torrid affair with amateur mother and a less Torrid affair with the other failed pilot.
与业余母亲的热恋，以及与另一位失败飞行员的不那么热恋。
We weren't that into writing.
我们没那么热衷于写作。
And far less Torrid and we sort of did that through the fall of 2004, or a carder and you submit drafts and you get feedback and we thought they liked it, but you know they buy like, what do they buy?
更不用说Torrid了，我们在2004年秋天就这样做了，或者是一个卡片员，你提交草稿，你得到反馈，我们认为他们喜欢它，但你知道他们购买的样子，他们买什么？
30 scripts, 30 pilot scripts and they make 10 of them.
30 个剧本，30 个试播剧本，他们制作了其中的 10 个。
Something like that, probably I'm getting the numbers wrong.
类似这样的事情，可能我把数字弄错了。
We didn't think we'd ever even be one of those 10.
我们没想到我们会成为这 10 个人中的一员。
Maybe they buy 50 scripts and make 10.
也许他们购买 50 个脚本并制作 10 个。
And then we were one of those 10.
然后我们就成为了这 10 个人中的一员。
By this time late winter spring was rolling around, they say you're like one of the 10 we shoot.
这个时候冬末春天已经来临，他们说你就像我们拍摄的十个人之一。
Yeah, it was back in the, I'll say the good old days of like when networks all development was on the same schedule, Like it was the, everybody, every writer in Hollywood who once has a TV show they want to make, pitches it like in the summer and early fall, and the ones that sell them, everyone is writing their script and handed in.
是的，那是在过去的美好时光，我想说的是，那时网络的所有开发都按同一个时间表进行，就像好莱坞的每个人、每个作家都曾经有一个他们想要制作的电视节目，就像在夏天和初秋一样，而那些出售它们的人，每个人都在写剧本并上交。
You hand it in right before, winter break, so like you, you know, go home to wherever you're going home to and just spend the rest of your time here for January, February and March, April.
你在寒假之前交了它，所以就像你一样，你知道，无论你要去哪里，都回家，一月、二月和三月、四月剩下的时间都在这里度过。
Yeah.
是的。
And then January is where they're casting them.
然后一月就是他们选角的时间。
Yeah.
是的。
Like January is when the phone rings and it's, okay, we're making it.
就像一月份电话响起的时候，我们就成功了。
they take those 30 scripts that they bought and they say, we're going to make eight of them.
他们拿着买来的 30 个剧本，说我们要制作其中 8 个。
And these eight pilots are going to get shot.
这八名飞行员将被枪杀。
And I'll tell this story, Craig.
我会讲这个故事，克雷格。
I don't know if you remember this, like, Craig and I were at, I think it was the premiere of American dad.
我不知道你是否还记得这个，就像克雷格和我参加的，我想那是美国爸爸的首映式。
There was a premiere party for American dad in Las Vegas and Craig and I were in Las Vegas and had a really fun night out.
拉斯维加斯有一场美国爸爸的首映派对，我和克雷格在拉斯维加斯度过了一个非常有趣的夜晚。
Yeah.
是的。
It might have been, I mean, it was before the very pineapple incident, very, very pineapple incident, which then became the head over like before the party because before the party, the phone rang and it was Matt Rice or maybe David Miner and it was like, let's get both of them on the phone.
我的意思是，这可能是在菠萝事件之前，非常非常菠萝事件，然后就像聚会之前一样成为了头号事件，因为在聚会之前，电话响了，是马特·赖斯（Matt Rice）或大卫·迈纳（David Miner）打来的，就像，让我们让他们两个都打电话。
So like we knew like, okay, they won't both of us on the phone.
就像我们知道的那样，好吧，他们不会我们俩都打电话。
This is going to be something.
这将会是一件大事。
And they said it was, it was the, the, the, the head of development saying like, we're good news.
他们说，开发主管说，我们是好消息。
We loved your script.
我们喜欢你的剧本。
We want to make it.
我们想要成功。
We want to make a pilot.
我们想培养一名飞行员。
So you're making a pilot.
所以你正在培养一名飞行员。
And we hang up.
然后我们挂断电话。
Yeah, we did it.
是的，我们做到了。
We go downstairs, we like celebrate, we tell all our friends at American Dad, they're like, oh, that's great, you're making a pilot.
我们下楼，我们喜欢庆祝，我们告诉美国爸爸的所有朋友，他们就像，哦，太棒了，你正在成为一名飞行员。
And like we have a great night, and then like wake up in like one in the afternoon, you know, and just kind of connect.
就像我们度过了一个美好的夜晚，然后就像下午醒来一样，你知道，然后就有点联系了。
And I don't remember exactly how this story unfolded, but basically like Craig and I are just like, oh, I'm making a pilot, this is good.
我不记得这个故事是如何展开的，但基本上就像克雷格和我一样，哦，我正在制作一个飞行员，这很好。
This is good.
这很好。
It's like a pool, yeah, I'm gonna relax.
这就像一个游泳池，是的，我要放松一下。
And like we get a call from somebody.
就像我们接到某人的电话一样。
I don't know, maybe it was Matt Rice, it might have been somebody, basically like, um, so when is your, how many, uh, casting director meetings have you had so far?
我不知道，也许是马特·赖斯，也可能是某个人，基本上是，嗯，所以你什么时候，到目前为止，你参加了多少次，呃，选角导演会议？
We're like, what do you mean?
我们就像，你什么意思？
He's like, you, you haven't, well, you have some book, right?
他就像，你，你没有，好吧，你有一些书，对吧？
You have some casting director, because what you don't know is that when it, when it's pilot season and you, your pilot gets picked up, it becomes this mad scramble supermarket sweep for the best talent.
你有一些选角导演，因为你不知道的是，当它，当它是试播季节，而你，你的试播集被选中时，它就变成了疯狂的争夺超市扫荡最好的人才。
And you have to like rush out there and find like, you have to, you have to book your casting director right away.
你必须冲出去，然后发现，你必须，你必须立即预订你的选角导演。
You have to book your, your director right away.
你必须立即预订你的导演。
You have to book, like, otherwise, they'll get snatched up and you won't get them.
你必须预订，否则，他们会被抢走，你就买不到了。
And so that became like that, like the story of January and February was us like scrambling to like cobbled together this rag tag crew who would like be willing to like take a chance on doodling dogs who expect you with a moment you got the green light for your pilot that you would just immediately start calling customers.
就这样，就像一月和二月的故事一样，我们就像争先恐后地拼凑了一群乌合之众，他们愿意在涂鸦狗身上冒险，它们期待着你，一旦你为你的飞行员开了绿灯，你就会立即开始打电话给客户。
So they clearly know that that call may have come from CBS, actually.
所以他们清楚地知道那个电话实际上可能来自哥伦比亚广播公司。
I think maybe CBS.
我想也许是哥伦比亚广播公司。
And we got kind of yelled at, they're like, what the fuck are you doing in Vegas?
我们被骂了，他们说，你他妈的在维加斯做什么？
Get a casting director, what's happening?
找个选角导演，有什么事吗？
Like right off the bat, we were just completely in overhead, didn't know how to, because you make this immediate leap from writer in a room, just coming up with ideas to CEO of a corporation that is being given seven figures to make a pilot.
就像一开始，我们完全陷入了困境，不知道该怎么做，因为你从一个房间里的作家立即飞跃，只是想出一个公司的首席执行官的想法，该公司被给予七位数的飞行员。
I mean, this was like just the mothership descending.
我的意思是，这就像母舰下降一样。
Like, look, it's literally the mothership.
就像，看，这确实是母舰。
Like it was like nothing like anything And then it's an all Z title for the podcast that's good.
就好像它什么都不像，然后这是一个播客的全 Z 标题，这很好。
Yeah.
是的。
I just wrote that down.
我刚刚把它写下来。
That's interesting.
那很有意思。
There you go.
就这样吧。
The Mothership Descend.
母舰降临。
And you have to suddenly put on this boss hat that you have never worn before really.
你必须突然戴上这顶你以前从未真正戴过的老板帽子。
And we that was the code.
这就是我们的代码。
That was the very hungover wake up call.
那是宿醉的警钟。
Get on the ball, guys.
加油吧，伙计们。
Go get it.
去拿吧。
Get back to Los Angeles, meet six casting directors, hire the one you're lucky enough that doesn't get hired by the time they're walking to their car after meeting with you because they just met four other people that morning.
回到洛杉矶，会见六位选角导演，雇用一个你足够幸运的人，但他们在与你会面后走向他们的车时还没有被雇用，因为那天早上他们刚刚遇到了另外四个人。
And if I'm a casting director, I'm going to choose anyone but us, Carter, because we looked 12 years old.
如果我是选角导演，我会选择除了我们以外的任何人，卡特，因为我们看起来只有 12 岁。
We didn't know what we're doing.
我们不知道自己在做什么。
We were hungover from Vegas.
我们宿醉在维加斯。
Like God knows what the casting directors were saying of us.
天知道选角导演对我们的评价。
We have backpacks on.
我们背着背包。
I think that's true, but I also just to give us some credit, I feel like we wrote a really good pilot.
我认为这是真的，但我也只是为了给我们一些荣誉，我觉得我们写了一个非常好的试播集。
And the further I get from it, the more pilots I've tried to write my life, and you realize like it really, there was something special to it.
我离它越远，我尝试写下我的生活的飞行员就越多，你会意识到它确实有一些特别的东西。
And it also, like, the great thing about it was it was this self-sorting thing where there were certainly a lot of people that had that reaction and said, no, and were like, no thanks.
而且，它的伟大之处在于，这是一种自我分类的事情，肯定有很多人有这种反应，并说，不，然后说，不，谢谢。
But that left more room for the people who got it, like, the people I found, and they found people.
但这为那些得到它的人留下了更多的空间，比如我找到的人，他们也找到了人。
And they took on a magical, this is very woo-woo, but it really did feel like it found people, including Mr. Josh Radner, and my God, it became, it became magic the way it found the right people.
他们呈现出一种神奇的感觉，这非常令人惊叹，但它确实感觉它找到了人，包括乔什·拉德纳先生，天哪，它变得神奇了，因为它找到了合适的人。
Well, it also, it also feels like something that everyone loves is probably not that special.
嗯,也是呢,也感觉大家都喜欢的东西,大概也没有那么特别吧。
Like a special thing is going to misdify certain people.
就像一件特殊的事情会误导某些人一样。
Right.
正确的。
You know, yeah.
你知道，是的。
And I think that and and I always think a project itself acts as a kind of glowing orb.
我认为，而且我一直认为项目本身就像一种发光的球体。
It attracts the right people and and and I do feel like how I made my mother had a kind of frequency that that brought people into its orbit who belong there.
它吸引了合适的人，而且我确实觉得我如何让我的母亲拥有一种频率，将属于那里的人带入它的轨道。
Yeah.
是的。
And namely, who actually is just a huge hero of the show who we all adore, but how did Pam Fryman, our beloved director, get, how did you find your way to her or her to you?
也就是说，他实际上只是我们都崇拜的剧中的大英雄，但是我们敬爱的导演帕姆·弗莱曼（Pam Fryman）是如何得到的，你是如何找到通往她或她的道路的？
I mean, that's the other, that's the perfect example and that happened and that she could have directed any pilot.
我的意思是，这是另一个，这是一个完美的例子，而且发生了，她可以指挥任何飞行员。
She was a hot in demand director.
她是一位炙手可热的导演。
She had been directing on two and a half men, which was like the number one comedy at the time, I think.
她一直在执导《两个半男人》，我认为这就像当时排名第一的喜剧。
And again, she was probably given 20 job offers that year, right?
再说一遍，那一年她可能收到了 20 个工作机会，对吧？
Carter, she could have done anything.
卡特，她可以做任何事。
She just read this and connected to it.
她刚刚读了这篇文章并与之产生了联系。
She said, I have to meet these guys, and she probably turned down other things to meet with us and come and basically said, this one got my heart.
她说，我必须见见这些人，她可能拒绝了其他事情来见我们，然后过来基本上说，这个人得到了我的心。
This got me.
这让我明白了。
The rhythm of this was different.
这节奏不一样了。
It melted my heart at the end.
最后融化了我的心。
It genuinely surprised me in the end.
最后这真的让我感到惊讶。
It's storytelling structure and the way it jumps around and she had not gotten to do, you know, play with that sort of rhythm before.
这是讲故事的结构和跳跃的方式，你知道，她以前从未玩过这种节奏。
And she just, she, she wanted to direct it.
她只是，她，她想导演它。
She, she basically said, I want to do this and we didn't think we could get her.
她基本上是说，我想做这个，但我们认为我们无法得到她。
We did not think we could get her, but she kind of chose us, which was amazing.
我们不认为我们能得到她，但她选择了我们，这真是太棒了。
Yeah.
是的。
Okay, so you've got this pilot.
好的，现在你已经找到了这个飞行员。
It's Greenlit by, bought by 20th.
这是Greenlit by，20号买的。
It's Greenlit by CBS.
这是 CBS 的青睐。
They want to make a pilot.
他们想成为一名飞行员。
You scramble for your cast director.
你争夺你的演员导演。
You got the hottest multi-cam director in town in Pam Freiman.
帕姆·弗雷曼 (Pam ​​Freiman) 是城里最炙手可热的多机位导演。
And then you have to find your cast.
然后你必须找到你的演员阵容。
Yes.
是的。
And then let's talk about that.
然后我们来谈谈这个。
What was that?
那是什么？
That was where things went wrong.
这就是问题所在。
That's where we finally had a break while.
到了这里，我们终于可以休息一下了。
Because I can, this is where I joined the story.
因为我可以，这就是我加入这个故事的地方。
I want your, I want your version of that story because you were day one, right?
我想要你的，我想要你的那个故事版本，因为你是第一天，对吧？
This just doesn't.
这只是没有。
This is another, every thing about the story of how much mother's creation, it never goes this way, including this part.
这是另外一个，每一个关于母亲创作的故事，从来都不是这样的，包括这一部分。
Day one, the Tarrantino version, without cut to Josh's story.
第一天，塔伦蒂诺版本，没有剪掉乔什的故事。
Yeah, let's, yeah, yeah.
是啊，让我们，是啊，是啊。
Back it up.
备份它。
Josh's story, P.O.V.
乔什的故事，P.O.V.
Switch, himium style, whippan flashback.
Switch，hiium 风格，whippan 闪回。
So, yeah, I'll just say I got out of NYU Graduate Action Program at 1999.
所以，是的，我只是说我在 1999 年退出了纽约大学研究生行动计划。
I was doing a lot of a theater.
我在剧院做了很多工作。
I was on Broadway.
我在百老汇。
I had done three pilots or four pilots.
我已经完成了三名或四名飞行员。
I can't remember.
我不记得了。
My first one I got replaced on.
我的第一个被替换了。
The second one got canceled after six episodes.
第二部在六集后被取消。
The third one never got picked up by NBC, a pilot I did with Rob Reiner.
第三个节目从未被 NBC 播出，是我和 Rob Reiner 一起制作的试播节目。
And yeah, so how I made him other, I think, was my fourth pilot.
是的，所以我想，我是如何让他与众不同的，这就是我的第四位飞行员。
I had gotten in the place where I was really good at booking them kind of quickly.
我已经到达了我非常擅长快速预订的地方。
Like I kind of cracked the algorithm a little bit, like I knew.
就像我稍微破解了算法一样，就像我所知道的那样。
And I also was very good at determining like, okay, I'm good for this role.
我也很擅长确定，好吧，我适合这个角色。
I'm kind of the right person for this role.
我是这个角色的合适人选。
And I remember how I made my mother being something that, and maybe this is in hindsight, but I remember reading it.
我记得我是如何让我的母亲成为这样的人的，也许这是事后诸葛亮，但我记得读过它。
And I just was like, I know how to play this guy.
我当时就想，我知道如何扮演这个家伙。
Like I absolutely know how to play this guy.
就像我完全知道如何扮演这个家伙一样。
I know where the jokes are.
我知道笑话在哪里。
I know what the rhythm is.
我知道节奏是什么。
I know when to get sincere.
我知道什么时候该表现出真诚。
I know when to undercut the sincerity with a joke.
我知道什么时候用笑话削弱真诚。
I just understood how you guys had written him and I understood it in some sort of like cellular way and I remember going over it with a friend because for the audition and I read through it like twice and I just knew it, I memorized it and I have found as an actor I've run this through with a lot of other actors, the better the writing, the easier to memorize because it's psychologically makes sense, like your next right move is the next right line that you want and when something's poorly written, it's almost like it has a hard time sticking to your ribs, right?
我只是明白你们是如何写他的，我以某种类似细胞的方式理解它，我记得和一个朋友一起复习了一遍，因为试镜的时候，我读了两遍，我就知道了，我记住了它，我发现作为一个演员，我和很多其他演员一起读过这个，写作越好，越容易记住，因为它在心理上是有意义的，就像你的下一个正确的行动是你想要的下一个正确的台词，当某些东西写得不好时，它是几乎就像它很难粘在你的肋骨上一样，对吧？
So I just knew that I knew how to play the guy.
所以我只知道我知道如何扮演这个人。
And the two scenes that I was supposed to audition with it was Kobe in the bar or Robin at that time in the bar was she throws a drink in my face, right?
我应该试镜的两个场景是科比在酒吧或罗宾当时在酒吧，她把饮料泼到了我脸上，对吗？
Yeah, absolutely.
是的，绝对是。
And then after the date gone awry where I have the model on to her, I stuck it being single, but I'd be a really good husband, right?
然后在约会出了问题之后，我把模特交给了她，我坚持单身，但我会是一个非常好的丈夫，对吧？
The big speed.
速度大。
So I remember, I woke up that morning, it was early mid-January, so one of my first pilot auditions of the season, it was raining, I remember that day.
所以我记得，那天早上我醒来，那是一月中旬，所以我本赛季的第一次试镜之一，正在下雨，我记得那天。
And I was bummed because I've always been like, what's the opposite of the pathetic fallacy?
我很沮丧，因为我一直想，这个可悲的谬论的反面是什么？
Like I look towards the weather to tell me what's going to go, what's going to happen.
就像我期待天气来告诉我将会发生什么、将会发生什么一样。
And I thought, no, this is supposed to be my good audition day, it can't be raining, but I got there.
我想，不，这应该是我试镜的好日子，不可能下雨，但我还是到了那里。
I walk in.
我走进去。
And yet, rain is an important part of the whole series.
然而，雨是整个系列的重要组成部分。
That's true.
这是真的。
I walk in Megan Bramman, the cast director, you two, Pam and Rob Greenberg, right?
我走在梅根·布拉曼（Megan Bramman）身上，演员导演，你们两个，帕姆（Pam）和罗布·格林伯格（Rob Greenberg），对吧？
Who was kind of, was he assigned to you guys as like a wiser steadier hand, like the older?
是谁，他是不是被分配给你们的，就像一个更明智、更稳定的人，就像年长的人一样？
Yes, that's a, he looked like a teenager's way and we look like baby soldiers and other ways.
是的，就是这样，他看起来像青少年，而我们看起来像婴儿兵或其他方式。
But he was a Frazier writer.
但他是一位弗雷泽作家。
It was like, what does Zookeeper is to chimps?
就像，Zookeeper 对于黑猩猩来说意味着什么？
That's what Rob was.
罗布就是这样的人。
Yeah, so that was the room.
是的，这就是房间。
A Zookeeper who sometimes flings his own poop.
动物园管理员有时会乱扔自己的粪便。
Yeah.
是的。
good for some food.
适合一些食物。
But Dylan was in the room, right?
但迪伦就在房间里，对吗？
Dylan was videotaping it.
迪伦正在录像。
They get branded in the cast ricker, you guys, Pam and Rob.
他们在演员阵容中留下了烙印，你们，帕姆和罗布。
I remember a little bit of chit chat about Ohio with Carter, right?
我记得和卡特有过一些关于俄亥俄州的闲聊，对吧？
Yeah, I mean, I mean, can we can we now flag?
是的，我是说，我是说，我们现在可以举报吗？
Cause I'll just to drop in like, oh, sure.
因为我会顺便过来一下，哦，当然。
For me, right?
对我来说，对吗？
Okay.
好的。
So now we're going to we're popping back and forth.
所以现在我们要来回弹奏。
Okay.
好的。
Go ahead.
前进。
Just go ahead, man.
继续吧，伙计。
Uh, for me personally, like, you know, Craig and I, we, you know, at the risk of, like, like, we, we, we never set out to make something that's like autobiographical.
呃，就我个人而言，就像，你知道，克雷格和我，我们，你知道，冒着像，就像，我们，我们，我们从未打算制作类似自传的东西。
Like, we didn't name the characters Carter and Craig, but there was like, we, we, it was a big starting point of single guy guy and guy who's just gotten engaged.
就像，我们没有给角色命名卡特和克雷格，但就像，我们，我们，这是单身男人和刚刚订婚的男人的一个重要起点。
That was a big starting point.
这是一个很大的起点。
And, and it was, we were, especially coming from, it was in a time in comedy, like, coming from, you know, writing American dad when like there was a lot of snark and a lot of like a lot of not a bad way but like a lot of like like shocking comedy and comedy that's kind of mean and zingers and stuff like that.
而且，我们当时，特别是来自，那是一个喜剧时代，就像，你知道，写《美国爸爸》的时候，有很多讽刺，很多像很多不错的方式，但像很多像令人震惊的喜剧和喜剧，有点刻薄和搞笑之类的东西。
And the the scary part of writing this was it's it was very vulnerable and it was very like honest and it was very true and it felt like like especially that speech that Ted gives.
写这篇文章的可怕之处在于，它非常脆弱，而且非常诚实，非常真实，感觉就像特德发表的那场演讲。
I remember feeling like feeling like this was like a page out of my diary and I felt like I was writing something that was kind of about my life at that time.
我记得感觉这就像我日记中的一页，我觉得我正在写一些关于我当时生活的东西。
I had been dating for a while.
我已经约会了一段时间了。
I had had a bunch of romantic mishaps here and there, like anyone does.
和其他人一样，我也曾经历过很多浪漫的不幸。
And I was at a point where I was like, I'm ready for the big time, but I can't find the right person.
我当时想，我已经准备好迎接伟大的时刻，但我找不到合适的人。
And so all of that got poured into that speech.
所以所有这些都被倾注到了那次演讲中。
And it was the kind of thing that I would think about my fellow writers that American dad reading the speech and thinking like, oh God, this is, but it's like, you know, but that's what makes it good.
我会想到我的作家同行们，美国爸爸在读这篇演讲时会想，天哪，这就是，但它就像，你知道，但这就是它的优点。
And that's why, you know, if it's scary, that's, that's why you have to, I think Arthur Miller said something like the writing, the best writing is the stuff that humiliates you as you're writing it.
这就是为什么，你知道，如果它很可怕，那就是为什么你必须这样做，我认为阿瑟·米勒说过类似写作的话，最好的写作就是在你写的时候羞辱你的东西。
Oh, yeah.
哦，是的。
Yeah.
是的。
For sure.
一定。
100%.
100%。
And, and so that, like, that speech hearing, we had never heard that speech allowed.
因此，就像那场演讲听证会一样，我们从未听说过该演讲被允许。
And okay, so I'm going to, I'm going to now give a little context to you walking in the room, which was we, we got a casting director, Megan Brandman, and she said, she, like, first thing, first meeting, I've got Ted.
好吧，我现在要向你们走进房间提供一些背景信息，那就是我们，我们有一位选角导演梅根·布兰德曼，她说，她，就像，第一件事，第一次见面，我有泰德。
I've got your Ted.
我找到了你的特德。
I have no idea who Robbins is going to be.
我不知道罗宾斯会是谁。
I've got some ideas for Barney.
我对巴尼有一些想法。
I've got some ideas for Marshall Lilly.
我对马歇尔·莉莉有一些想法。
I've got Ted.
我有特德。
We're like, okay, and I'm thinking like, oh, you found a guy from Ohio who went to a liberal art school like Wesleyan, which, you know, Kenyan is very, you know, I almost went to Kenyan.
我们就像，好吧，我在想，哦，你找到了一个来自俄亥俄州的人，他去了卫斯理安这样的文科学校，你知道，肯尼亚非常，你知道，我差点就去了肯尼亚。
They're very, very comfortable.
他们非常非常舒服。
Like, I'm sure you really have Ted.
就像，我确信你真的有特德。
And then so the, the, but then sure enough, first day of casting, first audition.
然后就这样，但是果然，选角的第一天，第一次试镜。
Like it was the first.
就像是第一次一样。
Right.
正确的。
Yeah.
是的。
For day one audition one, John, raining outside in Los Angeles, Josh Radner walks through the door as if he's brought New York with him.
第一天试镜时，约翰在洛杉矶外面下着雨，乔什·拉德纳走进门，仿佛他把纽约也带来了。
I think the rain was perfect.
我认为这场雨是完美的。
You brought New York into the door.
你把纽约带进了家门。
Yeah.
是的。
And, and, and first time we had heard these scenes out loud, read by actors by, you know, by anyone other than us, you know, in the privacy of our little like writer studio where we were.
而且，而且，我们第一次大声地听到这些场景，由演员朗读，你知道，除了我们之外的任何人，你知道，在我们所在的小作家工作室的隐私中。
So it was like, it was a big moment.
所以这就像，这是一个重要的时刻。
And this old man, he must have made me fell in love with you.
还有这个老男人，一定是他让我爱上了你。
New York City.
纽约市。
And now, commercials.
现在，广告。
Josh.
乔什。
Yeah, Alec.
是的，亚历克。
You have a new baby, a new child.
你有一个新的婴儿，一个新的孩子。
He's not so new.
他并不是那么新。
nine months?
九个月？
Is that new?
那是新的吗？
That's not that new, actually.
实际上，这并不是什么新鲜事。
So how have you started keeping track of his spending?
那么你是如何开始跟踪他的支出的呢？
What we're spending on him or what he personally is spending?
我们在他身上花了什么，或者他个人在花什么？
What he personally is charging at the at the local convenience shop at the at the five-and-dime?
他个人在当地便利店的收费是五毛钱？
Yeah, we decided it's not safe to give him money because he would like he does with everything else we had.
是的，我们认为给他钱是不安全的，因为他希望用我们拥有的其他东西来做。
He would eat it.
他会吃掉它。
He would eat it in his mouth and you know, money and coins.
他会把它放在嘴里吃，你知道，钱和硬币。
It's not what you want your baby eating.
这不是您希望宝宝吃的东西。
So we're We're keeping them off the money train for just a bit longer, but I imagine you have teenagers, right?
所以我们要让他们远离金钱列车一段时间，但我想你们有青少年，对吗？
So you're probably in the thick of the money game with them, right?
所以你可能正与他们陷入激烈的金钱游戏，对吧？
I absolutely am.
我绝对是。
And now that their money basically exists in the netherworld of telephone version, there's no cash, right?
而现在他们的钱基本上都存在于电话版的幽冥界，没有现金吧？
Used to be, you give your kid cash, tell him to run down to the chocolate shop, pick up an egg cream.
过去，你给你的孩子现金，让他跑到巧克力店，买一个鸡蛋奶油。
Yeah, you have no idea what this money is being spent on, but there's a solution for that.
是的，你不知道这些钱花在了什么地方，但有一个解决方案。
What's that?
那是什么？
Well, for all the parents out there were teenagers, we know you're already trying to keep a million different things under control.
好吧，对于所有的父母都是青少年，我们知道您已经在努力控制一百万种不同的事情。
Cash app is here to help make sure your teen's money and their spending isn't adding to that craziness.
现金应用程序可以帮助确保您孩子的钱和他们的支出不会加剧这种疯狂。
By sponsoring your teen age 13 to 17, they can get a custom cash app card, set personal savings goals, and even earn interest on savings with zero monthly fees.
通过赞助 13 至 17 岁的青少年，他们可以获得定制现金应用卡、设定个人储蓄目标，甚至以零月费赚取储蓄利息。
No minimum balance and complete oversight from your account.
无最低余额限制，并由您的账户进行全面监督。
New Cash App customers can earn $10 if they use code Family10 in their profile at signup and send $5 to a friend within 14 days.
如果新的 Cash App 客户在注册时使用个人资料中的代码 Family10 并在 14 天内向朋友发送 5 美元，则可以赚取 10 美元。
Terms apply.
条款适用。
Cash App is a financial services platform, not a bank.
Cash App是一个金融服务平台，而不是银行。
Banking service is provided by Cash App's bank partners.
银行服务由 Cash App 的银行合作伙伴提供。
Prepaid debit cards issued by Sutton Bank, Member FDIC, Cash App Visa, Debit Flex Cards issued by Sutton Bank, Member FDIC, and the Bank Core Bank NA, pursuant to a license from Visa USA Incorporated.
由 Sutton Bank、FDIC 会员发行的预付借记卡、Cash App Visa、由 Sutton Bank、FDIC 会员和 NA 银行核心银行发行的借记卡（根据 Visa USA Incorporated 的许可）。
See terms and conditions for the Sutton Prepaid Card, Sutton Debit Flex Card, and Bank Core Debit Flex Card.
请参阅 Sutton 预付卡、Sutton 借记灵活卡和 Bank Core 借记灵活卡的条款和条件。
Savings provided by Cash App, a block-incorporated brand.
由 Block-incorporated 品牌 Cash App 提供的节省。
Visit cash.app-legal-podcast for full disclosures.
请访问 cash.app-legal-podcast 了解完整披露信息。
Hey, Alex, yeah.
嘿，亚历克斯，是的。
Remember those legendary freezer pops from childhood summers?
还记得童年夏天那些传奇的冰柜汽水吗？
You know the one I'm talking about.
你知道我正在谈论的那个人。
The red, white, and blue ones.
有红的、白的、蓝的。
It is the only thing I remember from childhood.
这是我从小到大唯一记得的事情。
That's right.
这是正确的。
They pretty much ruled the neighborhood pools and playgrounds.
他们几乎统治着附近的游泳池和游乐场。
Your face should be covered with your finger.
你的脸应该用手指遮住。
It was just a delightful summer memory.
这只是一个愉快的夏日记忆。
Well, five hour energy has taken that iconic nostalgia and reimagined it as a bold, refreshing, firework freeze energy shot.
嗯，五小时能量消除了标志性的怀旧情绪，并将其重新想象为大胆、清爽、烟花冻结的能量镜头。
Every single sip delivers a massive flavor explosion like the original pops of which you speak, expertly blending juicy cherry, citrusy lime, and sweet blue raspberry to completely ignite your taste buds.
每一口都会带来巨大的风味爆炸，就像您所说的原始流行音乐一样，巧妙地混合了多汁的樱桃、柑橘酸橙和甜美的蓝覆盆子，完全点燃您的味蕾。
It's that fruity taste that you crave created with zero sugar So you can enjoy the full experience, guilt-free.
这是您渴望的零糖果味，因此您可以毫无负罪感地享受完整的体验。
Whether you're conquering a packed schedule, tackling a mid-afternoon slump at your desk, head it out on a weekend road trip or just looking to spark a vibrant new flavor sensation.
无论您是要克服繁忙的日程、解决下午在办公桌前的困倦、周末公路旅行还是只是想激发一种充满活力的新风味感觉。
This portable shot is the perfect daily companion.
这款便携式镜头是完美的日常伴侣。
Give your routine an exciting upgrade with a mouth-watering twist on a timeless favorite.
为您的日常生活带来令人兴奋的升级，为永恒的最爱带来令人垂涎的变化。
Ignite your taste buds with a firework freeze flavored five-hour energy shot available online at fivehourenergy.com or Amazon.
在 Fivehourenergy.com 或亚马逊上购买烟花冷冻口味的五小时能量饮料，点燃您的味蕾。
End of commercials?
广告完结了？
Back to show.
返回展示。
And then we cut to Josh walking in the door.
然后我们切到乔什走进门。
Josh is POV.
乔什是 POV。
Yeah.
是的。
So I remember, I remember we talked about Ohio.
所以我记得，我记得我们谈论过俄亥俄州。
I remember it just being like one of those auditions.
我记得这就像那些试镜之一。
And back then I was auditioning a lot.
那时我试镜了很多次。
Like I was not, I gotten pretty good at it.
就像我不是一样，我已经做得很好了。
Like I knew how to walk into a room.
就像我知道如何走进一个房间一样。
I knew how to do the minimal amount of chitchat that was effective and not too much.
我知道如何进行最少量的有效闲聊，而不是太多。
And I, but I do remember doing the first scene, it went great, the vibe in the room was terrific.
而我，但我确实记得拍第一个场景，效果很棒，房间里的氛围很棒。
I remember that felt really good.
我记得那感觉真的很好。
And I remember on the, when I hit that speech, I could feel Pam and I think Megan, like I could feel part of the way you know.
我记得，当我发表演讲时，我能感觉到帕姆和梅根，就像我能感觉到你所知道的那样。
And I think I felt you guys too, but I felt like, oh, this is where they wanted the speech to live.
我想我也感受到了你们，但我觉得，哦，这就是他们想要演讲的地方。
this is what I think they wrote and I gave them what they're looking for.
我认为这就是他们写的，我给了他们他们想要的东西。
And I don't remember if you guys had me do the scenes with any adjustments, I might have just read them once.
我不记得你们是否让我对场景进行了任何调整，我可能只读过一次。
Humor Boyd Megan said to you, what Megan said to you after you finished that speech.
梅根对你说的幽默博伊德，梅根在你完成演讲后对你说的话。
Oh, did she say, will you marry me?
哦，她有说，你愿意嫁给我吗？
She said, will you marry me?
她说，你愿意嫁给我吗？
Yeah, that's what I guess I'm going to propose.
是的，这就是我想我要提议的。
So that's a good, if for those young actors out there.
所以对于那些年轻演员来说，这是一件好事。
Yes.
是的。
If you audition and you get proposed here with a guest manager, you're probably going to get that right.
如果你在试镜时被一位客座经理向你求婚，那么你很可能会得到这个机会。
Yeah, you call your agent afterwards.
是的，你之后打电话给你的经纪人。
You say, well, I did this whole speech and afterwards, the cast director said, will you marry me?
你说，好吧，整个演讲都是我做的，然后演员导演说，你愿意嫁给我吗？
Do you think that's a good sign?
你认为这是一个好兆头吗？
So we all wanted to marry you.
所以我们都想嫁给你。
We all felt that way.
我们都有这样的感觉。
We were you melted our hearts.
我们是你融化了我们的心。
So I remember going back to my car.
所以我记得回到我的车里。
And so this is very inside baseball.
这就是棒球内部的情况。
And I don't even know if it's still this way, but you used to have to test for the studio and test for the network theory.
而且我什至不知道现在是否还是这样，但以前你必须测试工作室并测试网络理论。
These two hoops, if you got past the initial producer session, which is what I had with you guys.
这两个圈子，如果你通过了最初的制作人会议，这就是我和你们一起进行的。
So I, oh, also, this is maybe worth mentioning, my agent at the time who I was with for about 14 years, she used to tell me, the only power you have as a young actor is the ability to say no.
所以我，哦，还有，这也许值得一提，我当时的经纪人和我在一起了大约14年，她曾经告诉我，作为一个年轻演员，你唯一拥有的权力就是有能力说不。
And I didn't have much power.
而我并没有多大的力量。
I didn't, I wasn't a known actor.
我没有，我不是一个知名演员。
I was known in the business cast new directors new me, a couple, couple showrunners new me.
我在商业界广为人知，新的导演让我焕然一新，一对夫妇、几位制片人也让我焕然一新。
But I had gotten a reputation as being like a little picky as a young actor.
但作为一名年轻演员，我被认为有点挑剔。
And I remember Megan had pitched.
我记得梅根已经投过球了。
We were told that by Megan.
梅根告诉我们这一点。
I don't know if he'll come in.
我不知道他是否会进来。
He's picky.
他很挑剔。
So when you saw me on the list, you're like, oh, Josh Radder's going like, we thought accepted by you.
所以当你在名单上看到我时，你会想，哦，乔什·拉德（Josh Radder）会这样，我们认为你已经接受了。
We were like, he liked us.
我们就像，他喜欢我们。
The picky guy liked us.
那个挑剔的家伙喜欢我们。
Yeah.
是的。
We're so needy.
我们太需要了
So that was a real gift my agent gave me was saying, like, be discerning, you know, so I would only throw my hat in the rings for stuff I really believed in.
所以这是我的经纪人给我的一份真正的礼物，就是说，要有洞察力，你知道，所以我只会为我真正相信的东西而努力。
And I believed in your show.
我相信你的表演。
By the time I got back to the car, my agent called me and said, well, that was quick.
当我回到车上时，我的经纪人打电话给我说，好吧，那很快。
they want to do a test deal with you.
他们想与你进行测试交易。
They want to take you to the studio.
他们想带你去工作室。
Your car was 10 feet away.
你的车在 10 英尺外。
So then you guys also had a couple more days of seeing other teds, right?
那么你们还有几天时间去看其他的 teds，对吧？
We had to keep seeing other teds, even though we knew it's so shitty.
我们不得不继续看其他的 teds，尽管我们知道它很糟糕。
I feel bad because we knew we had you and then other people come in and nobody could be you.
我感觉很糟糕，因为我们知道我们拥有你，然后其他人进来，没有人可以成为你。
Great actors, great people came in and you need to go into the studio with a few in the network to test to go into a room with the executives and have you, and as it turned out, Kobe, do chemistry reads and see, we had to have that happen with a couple of other people, but we knew we were in love with you.
伟大的演员、伟大的人进来了，你需要和网络中的一些人一起进入演播室，测试与高管一起进入一个房间并拥有你，结果是，科比，做化学阅读，看看，我们必须和其他几个人一起发生这种情况，但我们知道我们爱上了你。
All of us were, and that's harrowing because we could have been, we could have had a different feeling than the network.
我们所有人都是如此，这令人痛苦，因为我们本来可以，我们可以有与网络不同的感觉。
The network would have been like, no, it's not him, and that would have been so heartbreaking, but everybody you went after the other went, we get it, and that doesn't always happen, either, kids.
网络会说，不，这不是他，那会让人心碎，但你追随另一个人的每个人都走了，我们明白了，这也不总是发生，孩子们。
That does not always happen.
这种情况并不总是发生。
Yeah.
是的。
I found in show business, and maybe it's like this in other areas of life, but if a job is not yours, the door won't open, and it just simply won't open, no matter how right you think you are for it, how much you want it.
我在演艺界发现，也许生活的其他领域也是如此，但如果一份工作不是你的，那扇门就不会打开，而且根本就不会打开，无论你认为自己多么适合它，无论你多么想要它。
If the job is yours, the door's keep flying open.
如果这份工作是你的，那么大门就会一直敞开。
And I've learned to trust effortlessness in my career, like when you click with people and it's easy and fun, and you're all just the enthusiasm is really high, you want to make this thing, it's like, I don't, I sometimes think effort, like hard grinding effort can be a little overrated, that you need to pay attention to where things are actually in flow.
我学会了在我的职业生涯中相信毫不费力，就像当你与人打交道时，这很容易、很有趣，而且你们都热情很高，你们想要做这件事，就像，我不，我有时认为努力，比如艰苦的努力可能有点被高估了，你需要注意事情实际上在流动的地方。
Yeah.
是的。
I've been running this while.
这段时间我一直在跑步。
And that's cool to hear you say that because I, you know, from the, and you've now been on both sides of the table having, having written and directed your own movies and stuff, like it is, like at the beginning of these sections, you get this list, and, you know, And here's who we're seeing today.
听到你这么说真是太酷了，因为我，你知道，从，你现在已经在桌子两边，编写和导演了自己的电影和东西，就像在这些部分的开头一样，你得到了这个列表，而且，你知道，这就是我们今天看到的人。
And it's like a list and it's like a name and then a little space for you to write your comments.
它就像一个列表，就像一个名字，然后是一个供您写评论的小空间。
And so it's just like a very clean sheet of paper with like nine names.
所以它就像一张非常干净的纸，上面有九个名字。
And you just like see that, you think like these are like nine people right now just hoping that that they're like, and it's by the way, it's this like nine different branches of like where the universe could go.
你就像看到这一点，你认为这些就像现在的九个人，只是希望他们就像，顺便说一句，这就像宇宙可以去的九个不同的分支。
This could be a show with this person as Ted, this person as Ted, and it's, it's, and I I feel like it's a lot of the stuff we talked about on how I'm in your mother because just the fact that destiny takes such a big part in the search for love.
这可能是一个节目，这个人是泰德，这个人是泰德，我觉得这是我们谈论的很多关于我在你母亲身上的样子，因为命运在寻找爱的过程中扮演了如此重要的角色。
I feel like how I'm in your mother at its core is this struggle between is falling in love something that I go out and seek.
我觉得我在你母亲身上的核心是这种挣扎，就是坠入爱河和我出去寻找的东西之间。
Do I take action to meet the person that I spend the rest of my life with?
我是否会采取行动去见那个与我共度余生的人？
Or is it something that happens to me?
或者是发生在我身上的事情？
And I have to just sit back and let it happen.
我必须坐下来让它发生。
And that's the casting process.
这就是铸造过程。
I mean, really is like, I feel like there's no way to, well, there's a good, no answer to that.
我的意思是，真的就像，我觉得没有办法，嗯，对此没有一个很好的答案。
It's an unsolvable question.
这是一个无解的问题。
There's a good, a good theme has emerged of our conversation of just like, there's some preparation and then there's some luck in letting you and being into that part too.
我们的谈话出现了一个很好的主题，就像，有一些准备，然后有一些运气让你也参与到那部分。
And you're right, Josh, and writing too.
乔什，你是对的，写作也是对的。
It's like, you can't, if you're forcing it too hard, that might be a sign, it's not quite right.
就像，你不能，如果你强迫得太用力，这可能是一个迹象，这不太正确。
And the doors did keep opening for you.
大门确实一直为你敞开。
In some ways, you guys had to honor the themes of your show in the creation of your show.
在某些方面，你们在创作节目时必须尊重节目的主题。
Yeah.
是的。
You know what I'm saying?
你知道我在说什么吗？
You had to be open to the right person at the right time.
你必须在正确的时间向正确的人敞开心扉。
So I'm trying to remember, so I go to the studio, you had one other guy there, I think another 10.
所以我努力回忆，所以我去了录音室​​，那里还有另外一个人，我想还有 10 个。
Yeah, the other guy we say it was.
是的，就是我们所说的另一个人。
We can say it was Bob Saggett.
我们可以说这是鲍勃·萨吉特。
He was a little too old for the role, and that's why he became featured at a consolation prize.
他对于这个角色来说有点太老了，这就是为什么他获得了安慰奖。
Yeah.
是的。
He was really good, but I was like, here's a little old, but no, no, I don't think we should say names of who it was.
他真的很棒，但我想，这有点旧了，但是不，不，我认为我们不应该说出他是谁。
No, no, no.
不，不，不。
That's not why I can't do anything.
这并不是我无能为力的原因。
It was just lies.
这只是谎言。
But very talented.
但非常有才华。
Another very, you know, I'm just going to, can I just throw this in?
另一个非常，你知道，我只是要，我可以把这个放进去吗？
It's someone, I remember being there and because you go to these things and there's two, there's always two, and everyone in the room, including the, you know, the head executives at CBS, everybody knows there's the guy that they want.
这是一个人，我记得在那里，因为你去参加这些事情，有两个，总是有两个，房间里的每个人，包括哥伦比亚广播公司的首席执行官，每个人都知道他们想要的人。
And then there's the other guy that they're bringing in just to show like, yeah, but we really want this guy.
然后他们引进另一个人只是为了表明，是的，但我们真的想要这个人。
And I think everyone knew that including both of the actors involved.
我想每个人都知道这一点，包括涉及的两位演员。
And I remember feeling just because my mind always says, like, how can I, how can I have more anxiety about this moment?
我记得这种感觉只是因为我的大脑总是在说，我怎样才能，我怎样才能对这一刻感到更多的焦虑？
Okay.
好的。
I'll feel bad for this guy.
我会为这个人感到难过。
And I remember because he was really, and I'm not to say who he was, but he went on to be super funny and great on another show that was that I was a huge fan of.
我记得因为他确实是，我不是说他是谁，但他在另一部我非常喜欢的节目中继续表现得非常有趣和出色。
So it was, it was, it worked out right.
原来如此，原来如此，结果是对的。
It was nice to see that.
很高兴看到这一点。
Can I say the, I do know this story that really made me laugh.
我可以说，我确实知道这个让我发笑的故事。
It's a Rob Greenberg line, because I think I also had to read a Barney scene.
这是罗布·格林伯格的台词，因为我想我还必须读一下巴尼的场景。
It was Barney trying to get me to go to laser tag or something in the test.
巴尼试图让我参加激光枪战或其他测试。
And Rob Greenberg apparently said afterwards about the other guy, I feel like he wants to go to laser tag, like he would go to laser tag.
罗布·格林伯格后来显然谈到了另一个人，我觉得他想去激光枪战，就像他会去激光枪战一样。
I mean, Josh did not want to go to laser tag with this guy.
我的意思是，乔什不想和这个家伙一起去激光枪战。
Yeah.
是的。
They're like a little jockeyier, a little different energy.
他们就像一个有点骑师，有点不同的能量。
Yeah.
是的。
It had to be plausible that you would not have gone.
你不会去一定是有道理的。
And you would not have of condolence or tagging.
你不会有任何哀悼或标记。
That's why you were right.
这就是为什么你是对的。
No, I'm just curious.
不，我只是好奇。
When people become so important and kind of iconic in your life, there's that moment when you see them for the first time that kind of gets etched in in your own personal history.
当人们在你的生活中变得如此重要和具有标志性时，你第一次见到他们的那一刻就会铭刻在你自己的个人历史中。
I'm just curious how you envisioned Robin Sherbotsky.
我只是好奇你是如何想象罗宾·谢尔博茨基的。
I don't know if that was her last name in the pilot, was it?
我不知道这是否是她在飞行员中的姓氏，是吗？
I think you came up with Yeah, it's, it was, it was a, it's your Robin, uh, kiddie Sherbotsky is a character from Anna Karenina, I think, I, like, I, I think I was like, I thought I was fainting myself a reader and I was like, I'm gonna read Anna Karenina and, and got like 20 pages into it and then you got what you need, you got what you need and that was it.
我想你想出了是的，这是，这是，这是，这是你的罗宾，呃，小孩子谢尔博茨基是《安娜·卡列尼娜》中的一个角色，我想，我，就像，我，我想我就像，我以为我自己是一个读者，我想，我要读《安娜·卡列尼娜》，然后读了大约20页，然后你得到了你需要的，你得到了你需要的，就是这样。
Yeah, exactly.
是的，完全正确。
So you, you, Tolstoy, I gotcha.
所以你，你，托尔斯泰，我明白了。
Did you have an idea in your head of who this woman was?
你心里知道这个女人是谁吗？
it's interesting because you've got five main characters, four of them were absolutely drawn from real life.
这很有趣，因为你有五个主要角色，其中四个绝对来自现实生活。
Like Ted, Marshall and Lily were me, Craig and Rebecca, you know, and again, like then.
就像特德一样，马歇尔和莉莉就是我，克雷格和丽贝卡，你知道，再一次，就像那时一样。
Then it becomes another writers come in and like add their own hang their own stuff on the Christmas tree.
然后就变成了另一个作家进来，喜欢添加自己的东西，把自己的东西挂在圣诞树上。
But and Barney was very much inspired by a couple guys that sort of were that that kind of false staffian presence in our lives when we lived in New York, the only character who was completely made up whole cloth was Robin.
但是，巴尼受到了几个家伙的启发，当我们住在纽约时，我们生活中的那种假职员的存在，唯一完全由整块布组成的角色是罗宾。
And so it really was like the casting process was sort of this process of like, let's see if we can find her.
所以选角过程真的就像是这样的过程，让我们看看是否能找到她。
Let's see who this could be.
让我们看看这可能是谁。
It really was like, it wasn't like, oh yeah, that, I mean, having those like, I think Neil got cast as Barney despite the fact that he sort of was physically nothing like the, the people that Barney was was based on, but like that, you know, I remember you guys talking around Jack Black was a prototype.
真的，这不是，哦，是的，我的意思是，有这样的人，我认为尼尔被选为巴尼，尽管事实上他的身体一点也不像巴尼的原型，但就像那样，你知道，我记得你们谈论的杰克·布莱克是一个原型。
Like, yeah, I think you saw him much more like that was bigger and yeah, yeah, there was there was like a Vince Vaughn road and like a Jack Black road, but we were more down the Jack Black road.
就像，是的，我认为你看到的他更像是更大的，是的，是的，那里有一条像文斯·沃恩的路和一条杰克·布莱克的路，但我们更多的是沿着杰克·布莱克的路。
I think that wouldn't you say Carter and then like, you know, came in, it was like, shit, that's good.
我想你不会说卡特，然后，你知道，进来，就像，妈的，那很好。
It's too good.
太好了。
But I do think the one, the one insight that I think we we happened upon that I'm proud of us for happening upon was is this feeling, because of course, you get picked up, and of course the first thing is like, who can we get in it that will help its chances of getting on the air?
但我确实认为，我认为我们偶然发现的一个让我感到自豪的洞察就是这种感觉，因为当然，你会被选中，当然第一件事就是，我们可以让谁加入来帮助它有机会播出？
Who's famous?
谁有名？
But there was a feeling, like, I remember thinking, like, so much of Robin is built into this moment where Ted looks across the crowded bar and sees this person.
但有一种感觉，就像，我记得当时想，就像，罗宾的大部分内容都融入到了泰德穿过拥挤的酒吧并看到这个人的那一刻。
And we see here for the first time as Ted seeing her for the first time.
我们第一次在这里看到泰德第一次见到她。
And if it's someone that you already have this built-in expectation of, like, oh, I loved her in this, I hate it or in that, like you're already, you're outside of the moment and you're not having that, it's not that that moment of like, there's a mystery here to be solved.
如果你已经对某个人有这种内在的期望，比如，哦，我爱她这个，我讨厌她，或者那个，就像你已经那样，你就在那个时刻之外，你没有那个时刻，那不是那个时刻，这里有一个谜团需要解决。
I mean, I want to get to know this person, but I can't be like, you see, you see a person and you're like, I know what you did last summer.
我的意思是，我想了解这个人，但我不能说，你看，你看到一个人，然后你就说，我知道你去年夏天做了什么。
I can't be.
我不可能。
Yeah.
是的。
It has to be like, I have to know what they did last summer.
就像，我必须知道他们去年夏天做了什么。
You have to not know what they did any summer, because tell me about your summer.
你不必知道他们每个夏天都做了什么，因为请告诉我你的夏天。
I think a mystery about me and Kobe's relative obscurity or anonymity at that point really served us.
我认为关于我和科比当时相对默默无闻或匿名的神秘感确实对我们很有帮助。
It served you guys in the story because you're, you're discovering these people.
它对故事中的你们很有帮助，因为你们正在发现这些人。
You're discovering them.
你正在发现他们。
And you want to feel like you, you've just happened upon them rather than having any, you know, sort of foreign knowledge of them.
你想要感觉自己只是偶然发现了它们，而不是对它们有任何外国知识。
Yeah, we, it was perfect who was more famous and who was not more famous in that of those five.
是的，我们，这五个人中，谁更有名，谁不更有名，那就完美了。
You know what I mean?
你知道我的意思？
like the perfect, the famous people fell into the right spots in the cast.
就像完美的一样，名人在演员阵容中处于正确的位置。
And, and, and we met you.
还有，还有，我们遇见了你。
It's the word met is in the title.
标题中就是“遇见”这个词。
It's about meeting people.
这是关于与人见面。
We meet Ted.
我们见到了特德。
We never, we've never seen you before.
我们从来没有见过你。
We meet Robin.
我们遇见了罗宾。
And that you're right.
你是对的。
It was like the audience met you guys.
就像观众认识了你们一样。
But Carter, it also occurs to me when you're, when you're talking about Robin being invented out of whole cloth on some level, she was the woman you were hoping to meet, right?
但是卡特，当你谈论罗宾在某种程度上被完全创造出来时，我也想到了，她就是你希望见到的女人，对吗？
Like, she was, you know, she became dimensional and, and spiky and all these things.
就像，她，你知道，她变得立体，尖刺等等。
But she was is like, what if I looked across the bar and just spotted this woman?
但她说，如果我朝酒吧另一边看到这个女人怎么办？
What would she be?
她会是什么样子？
For sure.
一定。
She was built that way, but it was a combination of, like, make her everything that would be like, of course, he falls in love with this person, but also give her things that it was almost like, you know, it's in sort of like judoing the, like, what's the tension of this series going to be like we've got this character this who just wants to you know his drive is fallen love he's like has this like he gets hit by lightning in this first episode of like ureka I want to get married I'm like ready okay my friend just got engaged I want to I want to settle down like how do we create tension and I feel like that sort of like naturally led to robin just becoming this character that her central drive at least at the beginning is I don't want to settle of that.
她就是这样构建的，但它是一个组合，比如，让她拥有一切，当然，他爱上了这个人，但也给了她一些东西，就像柔道一样，就像，这个系列的张力会是什么样子，就像我们有这个角色，这个角色只是想让你知道他的动力是坠入爱河，他就像在第一集中被闪电击中一样，就像我想要的乌里卡一样结婚了，我准备好了，好吧，我的朋友刚刚订婚，我想要，我想要安定下来，就像我们如何制造紧张一样，我觉得这种感觉自然会导致罗宾成为这个角色，她的中心动力至少在开始时是我不想安定下来。
But I do remember my first seeing Kobe for the first time, down a hallway, walking towards me.
但我确实记得我第一次见到科比，是在走廊里，向我走来。
And you know, you just have to do all this, you know, chit chat.
你知道，你只需要做这一切，你知道，闲聊。
And then you are supposed to, you know, simulate this thing together.
然后你们应该一起模拟这个东西。
But I do remember at, I think the network test.
但我确实记得，我认为是网络测试。
So it was just me by the time I think you, you, you just brought me to the network.
所以当我想到你，你，你刚刚把我带到网络时，只有我。
Is that right?
是这样吗？
Or did you bring both guys?
还是两个人都带了？
I feel like in the network you have to still bring two people, I feel like it's always there's always another person.
我觉得在网络里还是得带两个人，我觉得总有另一个人。
I can't remember.
我不记得了。
But maybe it was just you at that point because when you were with Kobe in a scene, that was the network, I think.
但也许当时只有你一个人，因为当你和科比一起出现在一个场景中时，我想那就是网络。
And that was probably just you guys.
那可能只是你们。
Oh, yeah, that was okay.
哦，是的，没关系。
So maybe the studio is a big deal.
所以也许工作室很重要。
That's the last step before you were officially hired.
这是您被正式聘用之前的最后一步。
Yeah.
是的。
But I do remember I had gotten I kind of would would get these waves of heroic confidence, like the higher stakes it got, I would get like a little more like, I'm going to get this, you know, like it was my, this competitive street came out in me.
但我确实记得我会得到这些英雄般的信心浪潮，就像赌注越高，我会变得更像是，我会得到这个，你知道，就像这是我的一样，这条竞争性的街道在我身上出现了。
And I would sometimes say things that were like, like just a little like Hutz-Bah-E in a way that was like risky.
有时我会说一些类似 Hutz-Bah-E 的话，但有点冒险。
But I remember when Kobe, she threw an actual drink in my face.
但我记得科比的时候，她把一杯饮料泼到了我脸上。
She had some water.
她有一些水。
and she threw the water in my face and everyone laughed and I, the scene's over at that point and I turned to the brass at CBS in 20th and I said as if this process weren't humiliating enough.
她把水泼到我脸上，每个人都笑了，而我，那场戏就结束了，我转向 20 号哥伦比亚广播公司的高层，我说，好像这个过程还不够羞辱。
And it got, you know, it got this like really big laugh and I felt like that was good, you know, I just want them to know, I always hated the power imbalance in being an actor and saying, like, please give me this role.
你知道，它得到了很大的笑声，我觉得这很好，你知道，我只是想让他们知道，我一直讨厌作为一名演员的权力不平衡，并说，就像，请给我这个角色。
And I always wanted them to know, like, I got something going on here.
我一直想让他们知道，我这里发生了一些事情。
I hope you understand.
我希望你能理解。
So I just wanted to level it the tiniest bit because it's so, it's so outsized the power when you walk in there.
所以我只是想把它调平一点，因为当你走进那里时，它的力量是如此之大。
And there are these executives that run But it's heated in like bleacher level, like theater, like teard seating, like it's a little fee, a little play just for that.
还有这些高管，但它就像露天看台一样激烈，就像剧院一样，就像泪流满面的座位，就像它需要一点费用，只是为此而进行的一点表演。
The whole thing's stage manage to make you nervous.
整个事情的舞台设法让你紧张。
It's not comfortable.
这不太舒服。
It's very stressful and it's on purpose.
这是非常有压力的，而且是故意的。
They want to see that you can rise to like the like really like under the gun and there's pressure in the air in that room.
他们希望看到你能在枪口下表现得像真正的那样，而且那个房间里的空气有压力。
And Carter and I of course feel like total frauds.
卡特和我当然感觉自己完全是个骗子。
We're sitting in these bleachers with all these executives.
我们和所有这些高管坐在看台上。
Meanwhile two months earlier, where the people you know bringing our little script to them, like please you know we were the you a month earlier.
与此同时，两个月前，你认识的人把我们的小剧本带给他们，就像请你知道我们就是一个月前的你。
And now we're in the judgey seats.
现在我们坐在评委席上。
And so I felt, I had such empathy for you in that moment, but you were great and human Kobe, the energy of human Kobe, undeniable.
所以我觉得，在那一刻我对你非常同情，但你是伟大的、人性的科比，人性科比的能量，不可否认。
I did feel loved and supported by you guys, by Pam, by Rob Greenberg, by Megan and Dylan.
我确实感受到了你们、帕姆、罗布·格林伯格、梅根和迪伦的爱和支持。
Like I felt like the people that I had established this rapport was in that first room were really on my side.
我觉得在第一个房间里与我建立了这种融洽关系的人真的站在我这边。
So I felt really, I felt some wind at my sales.
所以我真的觉得我的销售有一些风。
But I remember, I can't remember if you, we got the offer or it might have been a Friday, maybe had to wait till Monday.
但我记得，我不记得你，我们是否收到了录用通知，或者可能是星期五，也许必须等到星期一。
I can't remember.
我不记得了。
I think it was, I don't think it was immediate, but I got the job like within days.
我认为是的，我不认为这是立竿见影的，但我几天之内就得到了这份工作。
And then next, you know, we're making a podcast about this.
接下来，你知道，我们正在制作一个关于此的播客。
Do you guys know the West Memphis three, the three kids who were railroaded into, they were on death row for killing this.
你们知道西孟菲斯三人组吗？这三个孩子被火车撞进，他们因为杀人而被关进死牢。
I think girl, it was kind of a satanic panic thing.
我认为女孩，这有点像撒旦的恐慌。
And they were called the West Memphis 3 and they got put on death row as teenagers.
他们被称为西孟菲斯三人组，十几岁时就被关进死牢。
And they were, they were totally innocent.
他们是，他们完全无辜。
It was like an absolute sham.
这绝对是一场骗局。
But I think they were on death row for about 20 years.
但我认为他们在死囚牢房里待了大约20年。
And there was this guy, Damien Eccles, who I ended up doing in the evening at Joe's pub with this kind of evening of written letters.
还有一个人，达米安·埃克尔斯（Damien Eccles），我晚上在乔的酒吧里和他一起写了这样的一封信。
And I met him backstage and he had been on death row for 20 years and I introduced myself to him because I had just seen a documentary about them and he said, I hope it's okay to say that I'm such a fan.
我在后台遇见了他，他已经在死囚牢房里呆了 20 年了，我向他做了自我介绍，因为我刚刚看了一部关于他们的纪录片，他说，我希望可以说我是他们的粉丝。
I watched so much how I met your mother when I was behind bars.
当我入狱时，我看了很多我是如何遇见你母亲的。
Oh my God.
我的天啊。
Oh my gosh.
天哪。
I've never heard that from him.
我从来没有听他说过这样的话。
And I said, can I ask you like, what was it about the show?
我说，我能问你一下，这个节目是关于什么的吗？
I'm always so curious.
我总是那么好奇。
What was it about the show that that you wanted to see?
您想看的节目是什么？
And he said, he said it was fake enough that it took me away from where I was.
他说，他说这太假了，它让我离开了原来的地方。
But it was real enough that it promised a world that I was hoping I could rejoin one day.
但它足够真实，它承诺了一个我希望有一天能重新加入的世界。
Wow.
哇。
That's amazing.
太棒了。
And I just that always stayed with me that kind of like hyper real but real kind of quality and what that can do to people.
我只是一直伴随着我那种超真实但真实的品质以及它可以对人们做什么。
You can look at the show as diversion from your troubles or you can look at the show as a meta commentary on your real troubles in your real life, right?
你可以把这个节目看作是你摆脱烦恼的消遣，或者你可以把这个节目看作是对你现实生活中真正麻烦的元评论，对吗？
Like it's got this it's got this ability to meet people where they are that part of what we're doing Carter Craig and I keep talking about this mystery that we're trying to solves like, why does how I met your mother?
就像它有这样的能力，它有能力结识人们，他们是我们正在做的事情的一部分，卡特·克雷格和我一直在谈论我们试图解决的这个谜团，比如，为什么我会遇见你的母亲？
Why is it lasted so long?
为什么能持续这么久？
Why do new generations keep discovering it?
为什么新一代不断发现它？
And why does it seem to be medicine, like soul medicine for people in hard times?
为什么它看起来像是一剂良药，像是在困难时期的人的灵魂良药？
But you know, that story about Damian is like I think really illustrates something about that.
但你知道，我认为关于达米安的故事确实说明了这一点。
That's one of my favorite reviews of the show I've ever or assessments of the show.
这是我最喜欢的节目评论之一或对该节目的评估。
I think I've ever heard.
我想我曾经听说过。
That's beautiful.
那好美丽。
Yeah.
是的。
There is so much more to our talk with Carter, and you'll be able to hear it soon in a bonus episode of the show.
我们与卡特的谈话还有很多内容，您很快就能在节目的奖励剧集中听到。
So look out for how Craig met Carter if you want to delve into that sorted history.
因此，如果您想深入了解那段历史，请留意克雷格是如何认识卡特的。
It's not started.
还没有开始。
It's delightful.
真是令人愉快。
If you follow or subscribe to the show, all our bonus episodes will just show up in your feed.
如果您关注或订阅该节目，我们所有的奖励剧集都会显示在您的提要中。
So hit that subscribe button.
所以点击订阅按钮。
Also, starting next week, we will begin our official rewatch of each episode of how I met your mother starting with the pilot.
另外，从下周开始，我们将从试播集开始正式重播《我是如何遇见你母亲》的每一集。
We strongly suggest that you watch the episode before listening to our discussion.
我们强烈建议您在听我们的讨论之前先观看该集。
We know that most of you will have seen it once or twice or according to the amazing messages you have sent us 17 or 30 times.
我们知道你们大多数人都看过一两次，或者根据你们向我们发送了 17 或 30 次的令人惊叹的信息。
But it's time to start again.
但现在是重新开始的时候了。
So rewatch with us and if it's your first time watching, welcome.
因此，请与我们一起重新观看，如果这是您第一次观看，欢迎。
We're so happy you're here.
我们很高兴你在这里。
The very first day that we announced this podcast, we received questions and stories from around the the world.
我们宣布这个播客的第一天，我们收到了来自世界各地的问题和故事。
And we're looking forward to all of you sending yours in as well.
我们也期待你们所有人也发送您的信息。
Just go to the website, how we made your mother.com and click on contact.
只需访问我们如何创建 your mother.com 的网站，然后单击“联系”即可。
And here are just a few of those incredible questions and stories we receive from around the world.
以下只是我们从世界各地收到的一些令人难以置信的问题和故事。
This one is from Kajal in India.
这是来自印度卡加尔的。
Hello legendary people assuming I'm the first one to write.
各位传奇人物大家好，假设我是第一个写这篇文章的人。
Why would He assumed that.
他为什么会这么认为。
I don't know.
我不知道。
He was correct.
他是对的。
He was.
他是。
This was the first person.
这是第一个人。
Okay.
好的。
This is the first message.
这是第一条消息。
I'll forgive me.
我会原谅我的。
Oh my God.
我的天啊。
You were the first shot.
你是第一枪。
Right.
正确的。
I'm assuming on the first one to write.
我假设第一个写的。
And he was just wanted to wish the best of luck for this podcast.
他只是想祝这个播客好运。
Can't wait to hear what you guys have got to say.
迫不及待地想听听你们要说什么。
Thank you, Kajal.
谢谢你，卡加尔。
Wow.
哇。
Bad ass.
坏蛋。
Kajal.
卡贾尔。
Okay.
好的。
This one's from Michael and I ran.
这是迈克尔发来的，我跑了。
He says, every time the gang laughs or cries or in any matter emotional, I have these feelings too.
他说，每当这帮人笑或哭或任何情绪化的事情时，我也有这些感觉。
This one's from Mia in Germany.
这是来自德国米娅的。
First, thank you so much for this podcast.
首先，非常感谢您收听这个播客。
I'm rewatching the show every time I finish it.
每次看完这部剧我都会重温一遍。
My first tattoo is going to be an honor of him, you know.
你知道，我的第一个纹身将是他的荣幸。
There's no way to get this data, but I'm really curious how many how I made my other tattoos are in there.
没有办法获得这些数据，但我真的很好奇那里有多少我制作的其他纹身。
I mean, I feel like I've seen literally dozens in person, I've seen upwards, yeah, of a hundred.
我的意思是，我觉得我亲眼见过几十个，是的，我见过一百个以上。
I mean, it's incredible.
我的意思是，这太不可思议了。
So thank you for staying in your bodies with memories of our show.
所以感谢你们带着对我们节目的回忆留在你们的身体里。
That's commitment.
这就是承诺。
I like the show that much.
我非常喜欢这个节目。
Here we go.
开始了。
This one's from Daniel.
这是丹尼尔发来的。
He's from Peru.
他来自秘鲁。
He says, him, he's my comfort series.
他说，他，他是我的安慰系列。
I watch it when I'm happy, when I am sad, when I'm mad.
我开心的时候看，悲伤的时候看，生气的时候看。
I want to thank you Craig and Carter.
我要感谢克雷格和卡特。
I'm adding that for creating this piece of art and you, Josh, for giving your heart and soul to this project.
我添加这一点是为了创造这件艺术品，而你，乔什，为这个项目付出了你的心和灵魂。
I own a little music box that plays love Vian Rose and own a ducky tie.
我有一个小音乐盒，可以播放维安·罗斯（Vian Rose）的歌曲，还有一条小领带。
This one's from Julia in Austria.
这是来自奥地利的朱莉娅。
The show helped me through some of of the harder times, especially my quarter-life crisis, when seemingly all of my friends have been in relationships and I was still on my own trying to figure out life.
这个节目帮助我度过了一些困难时期，尤其是我的四分之一人生危机，当时我所有的朋友似乎都已经恋爱了，而我仍然独自试图弄清楚生活。
From Danella, from Chile, she wrote to us in Spanish and we got it, Google translated, which led to this.
来自智利的达内拉（Danella）用西班牙语给我们写信，我们得到了它，谷歌翻译，这导致了这一点。
I started watching this series about two or three years ago.
我大约两三年前开始看这个系列。
My husband recommended it to me and I became obsessed with each of the episodes, the story how the stories were woven in time, the flashbacks of the seasons, the pineapple, the pumpkin, et cetera.
我丈夫向我推荐了它，我开始沉迷于每一集，故事如何在时间中交织，季节的倒叙，菠萝，南瓜等等。
My obsession has been so great that my husband and I agreed that we would only watch it once a year.
我的痴迷是如此之大，以至于我和丈夫同意我们每年只看一次。
That's better English than I have speaking.
这英语比我说的好。
So good job.
干得好。
Everybody watch the entire series once a year.
每个人每年都会观看整个系列一次。
Is that right?
是这样吗？
Interesting.
有趣的。
Well, I wonder how many times she's up to them.
好吧，我想知道她有多少次是这样的。
What does that equal?
那等于什么？
And how long it takes to watch the entire series?
看完整个系列需要多长时间？
Right.
正确的。
Because if you watched one a day, it would be two thirds of a year.
因为如果每天看一次，就相当于一年的三分之二。
That's a good point.
这是一个很好的观点。
So it takes up a lot of your year.
所以这会占用你一年的大部分时间。
She's not minimizing it that much if she's watching it at that rate, okay.
如果她以这样的速度观看，她就不会那么最小化，好吧。
I love it.
我喜欢它。
This one is from Amanda in New York City.
这是来自纽约市的阿曼达。
There are no words to describe what the show how I met your mother means to me.
无法用言语来形容《我如何遇见你母亲》这部剧对我来说意味着什么。
But I will try.
但我会尝试。
I was 19 when I watched the show for the first time, which was only seven months ago, showed to me by my friend Samantha who claimed I'd love it.
我第一次观看这个节目时才 19 岁，那是在七个月前，我的朋友萨曼莎向我展示了这个节目，她声称我会喜欢它。
I didn't believe her at first, but that night we watched half of season one and I was hooked.
一开始我并不相信她，但那天晚上我们看了第一季的一半，我就被迷住了。
I think how I met your mother taught me it was okay to take time to get where you need to be, finding comedy and serious situations, especially the way the show executed it, is a metaphor that I've used in my real life.
我想我是如何认识你母亲的，教会了我花时间去到达你需要去的地方是可以的，寻找喜剧和严肃的情况，尤其是节目执行它的方式，是我在现实生活中使用的一个比喻。
You need to find the humor, enjoy, and even the most dire situations.
你需要找到幽默、享受，甚至是最可怕的情况。
That really is the only way you can truly get past them.
这确实是你真正能够克服它们的唯一方法。
I can say it with my full chest that this show saved me from a really hard time in my life and taught me it was okay and to never give up because in the end, you'll end up where you need to be and most importantly, you'll be happy with it.
我可以满怀信心地说，这个节目把我从生命中非常困难的时期救了出来，并教会了我没关系，永远不要放弃，因为最终，你会到达你需要的地方，最重要的是，你会对此感到满意。
This show is the the definition of trust, the process.
这个节目是信任的定义、过程。
And I adore it very much.
我非常喜欢它。
Carter and Craig, thank you for this show and Josh.
卡特和克雷格，谢谢你们观看这个节目，还有乔什。
Thanks for executing the most imperfect role in the most imperfect way.
感谢你用最不完美的方式演绎了最不完美的角色。
I love that.
我喜欢那个。
That's a great compliment.
这是一个很好的赞美。
Yeah.
是的。
Ted Mosby is far from perfect, but he's better because he's human.
特德·莫斯比远非完美，但他更好，因为他是人。
You did a great job portraying that.
你在描绘这一点上做得很好。
Thank you, thank you, thank you.
谢谢，谢谢，谢谢。
Wow.
哇。
That's beautiful.
那好美丽。
Thank you, Amanda.
谢谢你，阿曼达。
Unbelievable.
难以置信。
Thank you, Amanda.
谢谢你，阿曼达。
Thank you to all of you.
谢谢大家。
I just love that the framing of that was like flashback to when I was 19.
我只是喜欢这个框架，就像我 19 岁时的回忆一样。
By the way, I'm still 19.
顺便说一句，我还19岁。
I enjoyed the framing of that very much.
我非常喜欢这个框架。
I remember when I was 19, seven months ago.
我记得七个月前，我19岁。
I'm still 19.
我还19岁。
Okay.
好的。
I loved it.
我喜欢它。
Amanda, amazing message.
阿曼达，令人惊奇的消息。
Thank you for that.
谢谢你。
Yeah.
是的。
Fantastic.
极好的。
Craig, what's it like for you when you hear all this?
克雷格，当你听到这一切时，你有什么感觉？
It's mind blowing.
真是令人兴奋。
It's absolutely mind blowing knowing that it helps people get through a hard time and you know, gave them some sort of framing device for their own life in a way um yeah it's very humbling because we we started off here we are at the beginning of talking about this series we never could have imagined it with the two messages like that it's just it's deeply humbling and uh we don't take it lightly thank you best and you know i think that at your best at your wildest at the wildest edges of your imagining of what the show could be it's that right yeah no just you make you make art with the hope i hope it has it's like a message in a bottle.
知道它可以帮助人们度过困难时期，这绝对是令人兴奋的，你知道，在某种程度上给了他们自己生活的某种框架装置，嗯，是的，这非常令人谦卑，因为我们从这里开始，我们才刚刚开始谈论这个系列，我们从来没有想象过它有这样的两条信息，这只是它非常令人谦卑，呃，我们不会掉以轻心，谢谢你，你知道的，我认为在最狂野的边缘，在你最狂野的边缘，你会表现得最好。你对这场演出的想象是对的，是的，不只是你让你带着希望去创作艺术，我希望它有它就像瓶子里的一条信息。
I hope this reaches someone and I hope the message is not eroded and destroyed by the time it gets there.
我希望这能传达给某人，并且我希望消息在到达那里时不会被侵蚀和破坏。
There's something so great about you show something and they have the response and beyond even your response the response of what you would hope.
你展示了一些很棒的东西，他们得到了回应，甚至超出了你的回应，得到了你所希望的回应。
I just find it incredibly moving when art is received in such an open-hearted, sincere, beautiful way.
当艺术以如此开放、真诚、美丽的方式被接受时，我感到非常感动。
It must be really, I mean, we share in it, but you really, you and Carter and your team, pend the thing.
我的意思是，这一定是真的，我们共同参与，但你真的，你和卡特以及你的团队，悬而未决。
So I just think, I hope other people who are listening to how I met your mother, even other people, sorry, who worked on how I met your mother, you know, the props department and the editors, and I'm sure people who worked on the show are tuning into this.
所以我只是想，我希望其他正在听我如何遇见你母亲的人，甚至是其他人，对不起，那些参与我如何遇见你母亲的人，你知道，道具部门和编辑，我相信参与该节目的人们正在关注这一点。
I hope they also feel some sense of, Wasn't it incredible to be a part of something this special?
我希望他们也能感觉到，成为如此特别的事情的一部分不是令人难以置信吗？
Yeah, everybody put their heart and soul into it and it got a lot a lot of the people who worked on it.
是的，每个人都全身心地投入其中，并且得到了很多人的参与。
Josh and I included it making the show helped us get through some of our hardest times.
乔什和我把它包括在内，让这个节目帮助我们度过了最困难的时期。
I find it and I find that it just seems like some of that energy made it into the show like the show was that to us and creating it in real time.
我找到了它，我发现似乎有一些能量融入到了节目中，就像节目对我们来说是实时创作的一样。
And now people years and years later and people who are 19 years old and trying and going through their own hard time are feeling that in the show and it just makes me feel like we baked, we baked something in there that's lasting.
现在，很多年过去了，那些19岁的人，正在努力，正在经历自己的艰难时刻，他们在节目中感受到了，这让我觉得我们烘焙了，我们在那里烘焙了一些持久的东西。
And also this notion of watching characters go through hard times with this sense of chosen family and community and that they landed on their feet and they were able to laugh in the midst of hard times.
还有这种观看角色经历困难时期的观念，带着这种选择家庭和社区的感觉，他们站起来，能够在困难时期欢笑。
Like how am I my mother was still, it was brightly lit, it was trot on a soundstage, there's laughter piped in, it was a fantasy but it also So it was attempting to gesture at something very true about being alive.
就像我妈妈一动不动一样，它灯火通明，在摄影棚里小跑，有笑声传来，这是一个幻想，但它也是如此，所以它试图表达一些关于活着的非常真实的东西。
How We Made Your Mother Is Hosted and Executive Produced by Josh Radner and Craig Thomas.
《我们如何创造了你的母亲》由乔什·拉德纳和克雷格·托马斯主持并监制。
The show was produced by me, Alec Lev, and our co-producer is Doug Matica.
该节目由我 Alec Lev 制作，我们的联合制作人是 Doug Matica。
Our audio producer and mixer is Alex Reeves at Point of Blue Studios.
我们的音频制作人和混音师是 Point of Blue Studios 的 Alex Reeves。
artwork by John Morrow.
约翰·莫罗的艺术作品。
Please follow, rate, and review the show on Apple Podcasts or your podcast player of choice.
请在 Apple 播客或您选择的播客播放器上关注、评分和评论该节目。
It really does help the show.
对节目确实有帮助。
Our theme song is NYC by our own Josh Radner, special thanks to Lowly Kennedy and Elliot Connards.
我们的主题曲是我们自己的 Josh Radner 创作的 NYC，特别感谢 Lowly Kennedy 和 Elliot Connards。
Visit howwemadeyourmother.com to sign up for our substack mailing list and for links to our social media.
请访问 howwemadeyourmother.com 注册我们的子堆栈邮件列表以及我们社交媒体的链接。
You can also click on the contact page to send us an email or a voice message.
您还可以单击联系页面向我们发送电子邮件或语音消息。
Your stories and questions aren't an important part of the show.
你的故事和问题并不是节目的重要部分。
Subscribe to Josh Rydner's newsletters on Substack, read Craig Thomas' published prose at CraigThomasRider.com, and you can subscribe to my dead father's society also on Substack.
在 Substack 上订阅 Josh Rydner 的时事通讯，阅读 Craig Thomas 在 CraigThomasRider.com 上发表的散文，您还可以在 Substack 上订阅我已故父亲的社团。
To learn about how you make a difference, this shows ongoing campaign to raise money for congenital heart disease research, check out the Make a Difference tab at the top of our website.
要了解您如何做出改变，这显示了正在进行的为先天性心脏病研究筹集资金的活动，请查看我们网站顶部的“做出改变”选项卡。
This episode was made possible by the support of backyard ventures, marketing provided by Tink Media.
这一集是在 Backyard Ventures 的支持和 Tink Media 的营销支持下得以实现的。
People will, in fact, dance.
事实上，人们会跳舞。
Real question.
真正的问题。
It just hit me.
它刚刚击中了我。
Am I in love with you?
我爱你吗？
Or just new York City?
或者只是纽约市？
I remember in season one, we would have to drive somewhere else to sound mix the show.
我记得在第一季中，我们必须开车去其他地方为节目混音。
And I had the guard letting me on.
警卫让我进去了。
I was like, how I met your mother?
我当时想，我是怎么认识你妈妈的？
That's that reality dating show, right?
这就是那个真人秀相亲节目吧？
Yeah.
是的。
And I think I was like, yes, it is.
我想我当时想，是的，确实如此。
Well, the first reaction was always, sorry, what about my mother?
嗯，第一反应总是，​​抱歉，我妈妈呢？
You said, I'm going mad at you.
你说，我要生你的气了。